Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking and I answer
your question.
No,
it does seem like
I'm a cybernetic organism living this year.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers including
sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming and a lot of it took place with designers from around the
world.
And here's how it works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website and APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world,
we'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward.
And many of you who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers,
as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
goto 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim.
Okay.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
And my answer is inevitably Athletic Greens,
it is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my God,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty,
but more important,
it will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
So for me it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim.
Okay.
Hello Ladies and germs and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show
where it is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they are chess prodigies,
hedge fund managers,
professional athletes,
musicians,
actors,
politicians,
you name it,
Arnold sorts and anchor has been on the show.
We have people like Josh Waitzkin who's been on the show or the inspiration for
searching for Bobby Fischer.
But this time we have one of your favorites.
Categorically.
You guys love these episodes and we have a strength coach,
a hypertrophy coach,
any nutrition coach all in one.
Charles Pollock,
when is his name?
Charles Poliquin is one of the best known strength coaches the world.
He is trained elite athletes from nearly 20 different sports,
including Olympic gold medalists,
NFL,
all pros,
Nhl,
all stars and Stanley Cup champions.
And I FBB bodybuilding champions.
His clients include all sorts of folks,
but in that list you would find long jump,
gold medalist,
Waite,
Phillips and HL Nvp.
Chris pronger and MLB that's majorly baseball batting champion,
Edgar Martinez among many others.
Charles is currently teaching advanced hypertrophy,
nutrition and strength seminars alongside one of my favorite athletes,
Olympic weightlifting icon and medalist Dimitri cloak off.
You have to look this guy up and there is a photo of Charles who's now over 50
years old training with Dimitri and it looks like Charles arms might be bigger,
amazingly sky as a specimen,
both of them.
In any case,
Polokwane has authored more than 600 articles on strength training.
He is prolific and his work has been translated into 12 different languages.
He has also written eight books and his latest work is armed size and strength,
the ultimate guide and he certainly walks the talk with that one.
You have to see it to believe it and I'll certainly put some photos and the show
notes and links and everything@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast so you
can find links to everything that that includes our conversation on blood
testing,
neurotransmitter optimization,
hormone replacement therapy,
the good,
the bad and the ugly of that.
What to do with loose skin or stretch marks.
We covered just about everything,
his ideal breakfast and uh,
he is an amusing fellow.
So if you've never thought of a penis,
skin on your abs,
while he will give you some imagery that will help you remember all sorts of
useful tidbits that among many others you can find a lot more on Charles and his
latest@strengthsensei.com but in the meantime,
this conversation covers a lot.
I had a blast.
I hope you enjoy it as much as I did.
And here is Charles Poliquin.
Charles,
welcome to the show.
Thank you Tim.
I really appreciate you asking me to be on your podcast.
I'm excited to dig into all sorts of good stuff.
You and I have spent some time together and I,
I still remember,
I'm not sure if it's post traumatic stress disorder,
but the art that you did on my shoulder,
one of your seminars,
uh,
where I was,
I was held down.
I felt like it was a scene out of Oz or something.
But the,
uh,
you have a very wide ranging,
a very wide ranging expertise and that that goes all the way from you to art
active release technique and doing this manual therapy to the training,
the nutrition,
the supplementation.
When someone asks you what do you do,
what is your answer?
I simply say I'm a strength coach.
Uh,
but the tools I use,
I guess there were a bit worried than some
of my colleagues.
And how did you first become fascinated by,
by strength and also closely related to that?
Is English,
is English your first language?
Not at all.
It's French.
I didn't speak English actually til I was 17 and then as she learned English
because I wanted to be really good at strength training.
So the story behind that is that,
you know,
as a kid,
I remember looking at Tarzan comics or watching captain America cartoons and I
was always wanted a big physique.
I thought that was like the ultimate hero.
But what happened is that when I was about 14,
uh,
you know,
as I'm a recovering Catholic,
so I have to go to Catholic church every Sunday.
And to be frank,
I hated it.
And I only went there to prove on this girl called Lucy,
didn't you?
It was very hot.
And then one day she didn't show up.
So the next day on Monday,
I said,
Hey Lucia,
you weren't at Church that she goes,
no,
I'm 14 now.
And my parents say,
you can decide whether you go or not.
So I said,
if it's good enough for her,
it's good enough for me.
So what happened is I,
um,
uh,
there was a university library.
You still bought bottle was right beside the church.
So I said,
instead of wasting my time listening to what I thought it was bullshit,
I'm going to go to the university library.
And I was on the magazine section to periodicals and assign a French,
uh,
magazine appear article from Belgium called Kinesiology,
kinesiology.
And they talked about arthritis in the knee.
And I saw,
I read it,
it was in French so I could understand.
And I didn't speak English at a time.
So then it didn't take a long time to go through anything in French.
Today was about strength training.
So then I said,
okay,
I've got to learn English.
And I distinctly remember having to look up what bicep peak meant.
Like I said,
use the English dictionary,
bicep peak and the peak as in peak of a mountain.
I go,
that guy,
it's a figure of style,
blah,
blah.
And then so I learnt everything in English,
uh,
rather quickly because that passion and then I realized that all the best stuff
was in German.
So I decide to learn German.
And that's how I started.
I always,
always wanted to be ahead of the game.
So I always figured out who's the best teachers and then learn from that.
And I remember I was 21,
I would save my money up and I went to Jimmy that meet Raul phaser and I took
the,
uh,
German volume training from,
and I would see all the experts that I went to Finland and we Pavel call me and
have had deep Marshman blacker.
So whoever it was the best at the time,
I went to learn from them.
So,
uh,
that's how I started actually.
And you have it just a,
an astonishing memory,
factual recall ability.
Is that something that your parents also had?
My father a spork 14 languages,
so I guess he did a,
uh,
I have a great memory.
I think that's,
uh,
I basically taught myself how to read that.
My parents realized I knew how to read before I went to school.
So the way I figured it out is that,
you know,
we had a lot of,
I was the fifth out of eight boys,
so there was a lot of books around,
a lot of comic books in French and there would be like these,
uh,
word,
illustrate dictionary books.
Right.
So let's see,
I saw a fire truck,
you know,
French,
Kenyan,
Pompeii.
Then I said,
okay,
the code for fire truck is this.
And after that I start to read the comic strip called Asterix.
And so my father came back from Paris and he told my mom,
yeah,
he,
he's pretending knows how to read.
And my mom said,
no,
he knows how to read.
He goes,
that's impossible.
He,
he has a good memory,
is breathers read to him and he just recites like period parakeet and she goes,
no,
because I have the ultimate test.
So the French edition always came out six months before and then the Canadian
dishes.
And since my father knew that all his boys like Asterix,
you would always buy the latest asterix.
So you pull it out,
he says,
read this.
And I read it.
He was astonished.
I could read it in my muscle that told you he taught himself how to read.
So,
uh,
apparently my oldest brother did the same thing.
So it's a,
I was just wanting to learn.
It was bored to death.
So I would pick up reading.
That's,
that's an incredible,
I,
did your brothers also have an interest in strength training or was that,
were you the the odd one of the group?
Uh,
vibrators,
interests are quite different than mine.
I'm the odd one when the family got it.
And,
um,
I'm going to you,
uh,
ask,
ask a question,
the wording of which might be a little weird,
but I think you're known for quite a few different things.
What are your best friends think you're world class at the,
perhaps the rest of the world doesn't know.
Probably,
uh,
people say that and the best friend to have the worst enemy to.
Uh,
so the LCL,
I'll jump in front of a bullet for them,
but before I jump in front of book,
I'd write a killer guy myself.
But,
uh,
people say that I'm the most,
the compliment I appreciate the most is when people say it to me.
I wish I had a father like you.
So when they see me in track with my daughter and the way she A's and we,
she learns and they said,
uh,
Eh,
and I'm really well known to teach.
People have to have confidence.
That's what he said.
I'm a little class that.
So for example,
I had a friend of mine,
she's a single mother or kids.
Dad was absent.
So she left him with me for the day,
and when she came back,
the kid knew how to swim it and you had to ride a bicycle without training
wheels.
And she goes,
she did that in a whole day.
I said,
well,
teaching how to swim without fee,
it takes five minutes.
She goes,
are you serious?
And I told him how I teach it.
And she goes,
wow,
that's very simple.
So,
uh,
I guess I'm world class at solving problems.
Uh,
and people love my cooking.
Anybody that's been to my house,
but you know,
I cook man food,
you know.
So for example,
and make a chili with Yak,
a buffalo and elk and ostrich and you know,
people that have six,
seven servings,
they feel it.
But I like it.
I like to cook.
I think that's a,
a great way to be creative.
And,
uh,
I guess being creative is one of my biggest assets.
Um,
I,
um,
and I,
I love to think like a recipe and then improve it.
You're,
so,
I'm not one to stick to rules so much.
What is your,
so your,
your chili sounds like the Noah's Ark Chile.
It's a bit of every animal imaginable.
So what,
what is,
what are the ingredients in the Chili?
What's the key to making good Chili?
I think the key to making good Chili's actually blending the meats,
for example,
ostriches they're really high iron content,
but you might as well chew on a elite cold barbell plate when you eat ostrich.
Right?
It's,
it's so,
and then I take a use with a higher fat content,
uh,
like the Yak and then that kind of offsets it.
And I used to Alec,
but l for a lot of people that tends to be two gaming.
Right?
But when you have a buffalo kind of equals it out.
So,
uh,
and I've played with the ratios over the years,
but I think I've got the recipe down pat.
But the secret is it the Yak,
I think the Yak makes a huge difference on the,
on a pellet bill the of the meal.
Got It.
And is that,
that's partially thanks to the fat content.
Yeah.
And also because all the animals I pick tend to have,
um,
high omega three fat in them because it would be eat,
I mean,
the best meat deed in the world is white PT,
which is a type of deer that lives in north eastern Canada.
And you can only shoot it from an helicopter because there's no roads to where
the white PT lives and that needs is chased by walls all day.
So besides the fact that it's grass than animal itself,
which is really high in Omega three,
the animal is chaste multiple times a day by a wolf pack,
which makes the animal make glycogen,
which makes them eat a fatty and sweet at the same time.
You know,
it's like how it's almost like a fudge in a meeting.
So,
but the problem is is you're not allowed to import it into the u s so I only
made it when I go see my folks in Canada.
Got It.
Yeah.
You have to have to a pretty high barrier to entry if it requires a helicopter
ride and,
and sniping skills from the air,
basically.
So,
you know,
when I go to Montreal it know where to buy it.
And there's a place where my sister lives and get no where the avid in stock
year round.
But it is the best meeting Jerry come and him or in Montreal area.
I'll take you the teeth.
That means,
oh I'd love to.
I'd love to do that.
I've never been to Montreal.
They have very good tango there as well from what I hear.
But um,
the um,
the next,
the next question is kind of a sidestep,
but you have these,
these little nuggets.
And I remember one question that I get asked a lot you had to answers to,
which was how to get rid of stretch marks.
So what happens quite often is I'll,
uh,
people will follow any given diet or maybe not one of the diets and the four
hour body or whatever and they'll lose a lot of weight and then they'll have
this loose skin or stretch marks to contend with.
Um,
how do you recommend people,
uh,
mitigate or,
or get rid of stretch marks or loose skin?
What are your thoughts on that?
I mean,
if you're the type of guy who has lost so much weight that you can actually,
you Winster what you're a scrotum,
then here's the solution,
the,
there's an herb called got you cola and that herb will,
and I learned this from of the past quality was one of my early mentors.
Yup.
We'll get rid of what we call unnecessary scar tissue or an unnecessary
connective tissue.
The truth of the matter though is that you will see zero progress,
uh,
for that loose skin,
for six months.
So people say what?
It's not worth it,
but I tell people just keep doing it for six months.
And then it's almost like overnight.
This seems to be a saturation point where then the body gets the message to cell
signaling.
And then in matter of days,
and I've had,
for example,
people look like the AV,
15% body fat and they're actually 6% body fat when you measure them on a Dexa
scan.
And then when they do this,
a supplement for an extended period of time,
which is two tablets three times a day,
then,
uh,
overnight they tighten up.
This,
this is not an exaggeration.
Everybody who's tried it said the eye,
it's exactly what it is.
I mean,
add,
uh,
one of my best students who was a former pro bodybuilder,
yet a client came in any weighed 480 pounds and he decided to lose weight
because you would select this clothes the night before and you realize this
pants covered a whole bed.
So you enter this gym and after a year and a half,
he was done at 200 pounds.
So we had lost 280 pounds.
But I mean,
there's enough loose skin to Barry five cadavers inside of them.
So we,
um,
that's all my friend just gave him that.
And a year later I met that guy.
He was so thankful for that tricky because you finally got rid of the loose
skin.
So,
uh,
Gotcha.
Cola is the,
or you want to use for that?
Got It.
Got U K O la,
is that right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's two separate words.
Yes.
And uh,
are you using anything topically as well or is it all,
uh,
consumed all consumable.
There are some camp pounding pharmacists that will make you a Gotcha Cola,
a bioabsorbable cream that works a lot faster.
I would say if he could find the pounding pharmacist,
I will do that.
And it's a biologically active form.
Uh,
you could get the same results in about two to three months in Canada and nearly
early eighties.
You could actually buy it as a prescription.
Got It.
But it wasn't popular.
That's what Mauer used to recommend.
And then when it cream,
uh,
fell out of the marketplace,
the best alternative was to use the oral.
I see.
Then this is,
you seem to find a B because you have so many contacts and you work with so many
coaches,
not only coaches,
but also doctors in different countries.
I'm constantly astonished by the,
uh,
I wouldn't say shortcuts,
but just a very elegant approaches that you can find all of these just from
problems.
What are,
what are things that you believe that most other people think are crazy?
Well,
now,
okay.
We all know about the Chinese five elements.
Correct?
Right.
Maybe you could give an overview for folks who aren't familiar,
but
okay.
Okay.
So in Chinese medicine,
they believe there's five elements.
They regulate,
uh,
Al Fire,
water,
Earth,
metal,
and uh,
met them at open water.
You know,
the point is,
is that,
so in Chinese medicine they'll describe a condition as let's say excessive fire
or not enough fire or fire deficiency or water access.
And this was very poetic,
but now science has backed up what it means in Chinese medicine.
For example,
osteoporosis and the adrenal fatigue or the same thing while in western
medicine,
it's not so years ago,
add observed at training the training of athletes as to be individualized.
So for example,
you know,
when you talk like let's say about squat,
two of my favorite people on earth or Ed Coan and John wrote,
and in order to get a big squad,
but if you look at the way day gets you to,
I have a big squad,
it's diametrically opposed,
but the keys not to say,
well one is better than the other would.
The key is,
is what is best for you.
And I studied the Chinese medicine approach on it.
What I've figured out is that it's actually a neurotransmitter dominance if you
want to explain it into the modern world.
So some athletes make a lot of dope.
They mean they need a lot of variation.
There were cows,
they need to go balls to the walls,
every workout.
Uh,
but they need variation.
If they don't have variation every workout,
they don't make progress.
While some people are what I call earth type,
which I don't have a any dominance,
and then they,
it,
they're more like Thomas the tank engine.
It's slow progress.
All that training methods is based on patients.
They never miss a live,
you know,
and that method works for them.
And in bodybuilding,
you've seen that you've seen in every sport lately,
even look at wrestling.
Of course three girls are on national team and one is dopamine,
the dominant.
And she's like,
uh,
among goose on TCP,
when she fights,
she's really hard to predict what she does.
And then the,
you know,
esoteric Coleen dominant one where she's,
she has a style that confuses people.
And then I've heard type wrestlers number one in the world right now.
And she's very patient when she fights and you know,
she'll arm lock you in and she waits,
she waits,
she waits and she tires you out.
And she's not a dominant in any neuro transmitters which would make her her
earth type,
you know?
So over the,
so now people,
when I started to talking about the elements,
people say,
oh he's like granola had bullshit or blah blah blah.
And then now my most popular courses actually advanced program design.
And if you look at the reviews on my website,
if people say that's the fastest way to individualize the training process and
we really big on individualization,
I think that people want a cookie cutter approach and they don't like the fact
that when I answer a question,
if you ask me a question,
what's the best way to screw in a screw?
I'll say a screwdriver.
And they'll say,
why didn't you say a saw?
Well I don't have time to explain to you that the screwdriver you is the best
tools that I've been considered rigid in my approach.
But I'm not,
I've done a lot of trial and error.
But if you've got an ask me for,
uh,
a solution,
I'll tell you the quickest way to get there at all.
And I'll have time to educate everybody,
you know.
So in that with the neurotransmitter dominance,
how do you determine,
or how does one determine
which category they fall into?
I actually,
I think,
I mean,
they've just been a lot of efforts clinically to do,
let's say,
so I ever work or a year and work and even the labs we've done,
the research says it's kind of a useless,
okay.
So if you look at catching Wilner who has won the cone of the Nobel Prize for
functional medicine,
she is a big advocate of,
um,
the Braverman test,
which you could download for free.
Uh,
you just Google Eric Braverman the Braverman test and it's a multiple,
uh,
at question answer type of format.
And I thought she found,
and so that bill bill echoes and over in your transmitter expert to find that to
be the,
actually the most accurate test.
But you can only do it once in your life.
And because if you redo the questionnaire,
you know the questions and then you'll,
there'll be an internal bias to the answer.
But if you answer it truthfully,
um,
and then what you find is that this true complete dominance is right,
are rare,
but you will find that you say more firewood or what I call,
they'll pay me in us steel,
Coleen dependent.
So you need both.
And there's always a limiting factor when you did the test.
So you could have,
let's say be Johnny Dopamine,
but you lacked Gaba.
So your biggest limiting,
you can't have what we call centered calmness,
you know,
which is what the gap I said a new transmitter for.
So,
or it could be dopamine dominant like Uber,
dopamine boy.
But what happens is that you have the whole serotonin so you don't have any fun
in your life.
And the fact that she did I though do you fun is actually a limiting factor to
your progress.
So I think,
you know,
they say know yourself.
Uh,
yeah,
that's the first thing you should do.
So I,
when I teach the class,
I make all my students do the test.
And then for three days I explain out to be individualized depending on what
physical quality you want.
So let's say if you want to get big and you don't bring the dependent aside
should do it.
And then I give the in between and then the most common comments is now the
progress or achieve with my students or my clients as much faster.
And you know,
for years,
I remember when I had my facility in Phoenix,
I would have let's say 10 hockey player string at the same time and the guys
will look at each other's program and they thought maybe at some favorite,
uh,
everybody had their best program for them,
you know.
Uh,
so the,
uh,
I think that's one of the keys to success.
I mean,
there's a lot of ways to get there,
but you got to find what's the best way for you,
you know?
Um,
I mean if you go ahead.
Oh No,
I was just going to say,
I think you also touched on something that's very important,
which is the testing effect.
So you'll the in so many different areas of life,
whether it's athletics,
academics,
uh,
even very smart people make the mistake of looking at someone who say,
or a cohort of people who take the same test multiple times and they assume that
some type of intervention,
whether it's a supplement or a training program,
is improving their performance.
But it's like,
no,
you have to,
you have to at least ask the question,
what if they're only getting better at the test?
Right?
And,
and that,
that,
that I think that is probably has a lot of implications for diagnosis with,
with athletes as well.
I don't,
I don't know,
but I mean yourself,
you had the epitome of self testing,
right?
So I mean,
that's one of your keys to success.
You are willing to be the lab rat for all of us,
right?
So the advantage with me is that bad,
a lot of the lab rats who wanted to go the Olympics and I tried different
things,
but you know,
one of the critiques I often get is you're not scientific or you don't like
science.
Well,
here's my answers to these detractors
clinical experience,
uh,
beats,
research studies.
I'll give you an example.
In February,
2008,
in the Journal of applied a strength and conditioning,
there was a paper cluster training and novel approach to strength training or
the development of relative strength.
Okay.
That's February,
2008.
I a new question training in 1975 was 14 years old.
So if I use cluster training with all the sports where I needed relative
strength,
I started to be a strength coach in [inaudible] 78.
So if you look at it,
uh,
the difference between 78 and 2008 is very big and quite a few Olympics in
between.
Right?
Do you agree?
So if you look at that,
if I waited for research to do the right type of training that produced sounds
like medalist,
I would have wasted about a few dozen Olympics.
So they,
yes,
that winter and summer.
So the point is that when the article came out,
I said,
that's an interesting,
it's novel in 2008.
So as my coach,
where did you learn about cluster at training?
He says,
I learned it in 68 in Paris.
And I said,
okay,
where do you think it came from?
And we did some background research and we think it was first developed by our
Bhag and coach in 1948.
Okay.
So then we have about 60 years,
uh,
of between when the clinician develop the method and when the research was
actually done.
Right.
So for example,
I used to,
early on had been recommended high doses or fish or 30 to 45 grams.
And then the biggest amount of research,
uh,
official news and research at the time was seven grams with the med school
students.
And then I convinced Mark Houston,
he was an MD to use high dosages.
And then he says,
wow,
it's really good for dyslipidemia.
I blood pressure,
cardiovascular risk,
and it doubled my business.
Why did it double Your Business?
Mark Walters,
my patient's cells in fat and now people are coming in for fat loss and not for
treating vascular disorders.
And five or seven years after I convinced them,
there was a Kenyan research paper that came out that said to treat obesity,
the best dose official was 60 grams.
And mark sent me an email and the title was clinicians always ahead of the curve
and he says,
I don't know if you read the study.
And he showed it to me.
And then the interesting thing was is that why did I come up with 30 of the 45
grams official?
Okay.
I did not have peered reviewed studies,
but the human genome evolved most dramatically.
Once we got our Omega threes to 300 to 400 grams per week.
You know,
we used to eat animal brains and we used to suck on femurs of analogs and stuff
like that.
And when the human start to ingest a lot of Omega threes,
birth three Dha,
our brains heal very fast when you're able to develop tools and so on.
So a lot of the stuff I do may not be peer reviewed based,
but in essence,
basic sciences,
basic science,
you know.
And then if you,
if your principles are sound,
then,
and
to be frank,
I don't really give a shit about the detractors because,
you know,
uh,
research always back me up,
but sometimes 20 to 40 years after I had done it.
So clinic,
clinical experience,
uh,
you can't beat that.
Yeah.
And I,
and I,
I think it's important also for people to realize that there's a value in a
place for peer reviewed placebo controlled studies,
but they're also very slow.
They require funding.
Uh,
there are a lot of regulations and in different areas related to those types of
studies.
And like you said,
science is not a,
a study sciences.
Uh,
scientific thinking is scientific thinking,
right?
I mean,
you're forming a hypothesis,
you're testing that hypothesis,
trying to disprove it,
looking at alternative explanations for the outcome and kind of rinsing and
repeating.
So I think that it's,
um,
there's a really good book on this called bad science by Guy Ben Goldacre that I
think everybody should be required to read just so they can parse.
Um,
it's kind of the sensationalist bullshit that they see in say the newspaper from
what the real science actually says.
A quick question on the fish oil.
Is there
just on that?
Furthermore,
I think it should be a required reading to have a Facebook account because this
way you would stop making those dumb comments if you had that book.
And you know,
I agree 100% with you.
The other thing too is that we don't know if one of the subjects did ecstasy on
a weekend and stayed up,
you know,
there's a lot of shit and we can't control.
So,
uh,
yes,
you do have to have a scientific basis to what you do.
And I'm in full agreement.
What's also kind of frustrating for me is that people give so much credence to
say long Longitudinal observational studies that are depending on people's self
reporting,
when they can remember or misremember whenever they write down,
but they discount the sort of small sample size experimental studies that,
for instance,
you've been doing with athletes for decades.
Uh,
it's very,
very frustrating.
Um,
but the,
um,
quick question on the,
on the fish oil is a,
is there any risk of,
uh,
any type of intestinal bleeding or anything like that with extremely high,
what,
what most people would consider high dosages of fish oil.
Wow.
And they're seen it.
But when I use fish oil in high dosages,
I never use it more than six months.
The reason why I found that I don't need to go along to six months is six
months.
You should have attained your body composition goal,
but if you do free fatty acid profiles,
uh,
on a regular basis,
you find that after six months everything is pretty well set.
And then you only need a maintenance.
And if the person eats a lot of wild meat,
a lot of,
uh,
c products,
I give them no fish oil.
So for example,
myself,
uh,
from May to October,
I don't take any official because back home I eat the wild meat.
I like to eat the fish,
blah,
blah.
But of course if I go to England,
where there a set of stage is more
like a hockey puck,
you won't,
you're that good at we get three supply.
But even,
you know,
I get regular blood work and I found that for me at age 54 when I'm on a fish or
a program,
it's two grams a day,
which is nothing,
right?
But you know the every single gene in the human genome as a receptor site for
when we get threes.
So Margaret Basketball,
he taught me this in 94,
he says,
if you look at any medical scientific database,
it is impossible not to find the study where we get three LEDs,
symptoms of all disease known to man.
And I said,
that was bullshit.
So yet there is on database yet 8 million scientific references.
It's just punch in whatever you want.
So Punch Preeclampsia.
I tried to come up with anything you'd like,
add,
Adhd,
uh,
try Somik children,
whatever.
And then in every single,
uh,
ailment,
I punched in with the keyword and we get three F on at least one study.
Okay.
But I read the,
the,
the test two years ago and the minimum amount of Steve's I found,
whereas the beneficial outcome with,
and we go through therapy was 14 for any disease I could punch in.
So,
uh,
you know,
the 3:00 AM I get three and thyroid aren't necessary for every gene in the human
genome.
That's what we know so far.
Uh,
it's probably more,
but,
um,
uh,
as far as intestinal bleeding,
clinically I've used very high dosages,
like 60 grams and,
and there were seen it,
but maybe it's the,
whoever you work with,
I tend to work with healthier than average,
uh,
population.
And,
but then again,
according to Dr Rakowski,
only two to 3% of Americans would be considered healthy.
Yeah.
The net death.
Speaking of,
um,
you,
you mentioned Margie Pasquale,
so he,
I think introduced me first to what he,
what he was calling the anabolic diet when I was back,
when I was in high school.
Uh,
which,
if I'm remembering correctly,
it was on some level of cyclical ketogenic diet.
A Am I,
I don't think I'm butchering that,
but no.
I was also introduced to your writing through muscle media 2000 way back in the
early days.
Uh,
what have you changed your mind about over time?
What are a,
what are things that you've most change,
changed your mind about over,
over the last decade or two?
The most important thing that I've learned about nutrition is you need to
deserve your cars.
So if you look at the world average carbohydrate intake should be about 40% that
would be healthy cardboard.
But it's the average.
It's not the individual.
So if you the language in any way from Tuktoyaktuk and
Nick [inaudible],
north
Lt carbohydrate intake forms,
probably 2% because each whale blubber and Arvold a seal and so on.
So I had a guy who played in the Ahl use fat and it should,
you know,
you're a native,
uh,
inward.
Why don't you eat like a native intuit when you go back home?
And he went and he went from something like a 21% body fat to a 6% body fat
eating 70% fat and 30% protein and zero carbohydrates.
Right?
So I find that you,
you have to figure out what your set point for carbohydrates,
but most people,
the too many carbohydrates are actually drink too when you carb or grades.
And then the carburetors would eat the wrong type.
People perceive me as a cardboard read Nazi and not,
you know,
our [inaudible] Nancy.
The thing is is that I got some athletes who do best on 70% carbs,
20% protein,
10% fat,
but they deserve their carbohydrates.
They got a great pancreas.
The insulin sensitive about if you've got a lot of muscle mass,
but some athletes,
you know,
they are allowed 10 licks of a dried prune every six months.
That's,
that's all they deserve.
And that's all they will get.
And after six months,
they're actually allowed to look at calendar pictures of cakes once a week.
But,
but I think that the,
the most important they learned from Mario is that
I remember asking my Arrow this question,
he is one of the best people I've ever had the chance,
you know,
and the honor to talk to.
And he told me,
he says in nutrition there's what we call the 70% rule.
And I find that to be true and training,
70% of the advice is good for 70% and 7%.
The advice is only good for 70% of the population and the IGA 15% on each side,
there are outliers.
So the 70% rule for carbohydrates should be 40% if URL.
Okay.
And then some of the guys do very well on 70%.
Okay?
So,
uh,
I think that you,
you have to monitor yourself if things like your morning insulin,
your morning glucose,
you're reactive insulin test you,
HB one ac,
you do those four tests and you start with a starting point.
And,
uh,
you do these tests for the every eight weeks would be enough.
And then you'll find what's best for you.
That's what I tell my students do.
Um,
and then it could you elaborate on the,
each of those tests just so people can,
uh,
and we'll put this in the show notes as well,
but I think,
I think people would love to know,
uh,
if you could just go through those,
those bullets and just describe a little bit for context each of those.
Well,
the purpose of each of those tests,
well,
morning glucose,
morning insulin,
you know,
our base old tests.
So the,
it gives you a reference value.
But one thing you have to be wary of is what we call the norms.
When you think norms,
you should think of homer Simpson.
Okay.
So for example,
morning glucose,
the norms to most American labs is 70 to 99 in the morning.
Okay.
That's after a 12 hour fast.
The problem is,
is that your risk of cardiovascular disease increases 5% after every single
digit above 70.
So in other words,
you could have 99 and be in a normal range,
but your cardiovascular risk is actually 145% greater than thought it was 70.
Right.
So there's a difference between normal and optimal.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I'd rather you have 70 than to be between 70 and 99.
The next value I'd like to check is,
um,
HB one AC,
which is basically measures how much you're emo Globan,
which is your oxygen carrying molecule has been damaged by glucose.
And then,
uh,
when,
depending on the country,
you know,
the alarm point is set differently.
Some people's FivePoint lines,
we will sit 6.9.
But the truth of the matter is the lower your score is a bit of this,
then it means you have less damage done to your hemoglobin.
But what's interesting is that,
you know,
when you cut it,
it's a lie detector test for cardboard read intake.
In other words,
you come to see me unless he bring a friend who was obese and he said,
Charles,
take care of him.
And I do that test and he's 5.9 and he goes on a low carb diet and he shows up
at 6.16 weeks later while he's a bullshit artist because you know that you
cannot fake that test.
So one thing that I've found over the years is that actually the amount of
magnesium supplemental magnesium you consume is the fastest way to drop that
value.
So magnesium is probably one of the best anti aging minerals.
And they say that basically you age at the rate you produce insulin.
So the HB one ac will tell me what,
what was the average insulin or the last three months,
you know,
so that's a good key.
Another test I really like is the reactive insulin tests.
So you submit blood,
uh,
for the morning draw at any two rice cakes with um,
jam on it.
Uh,
let's say a tablespoon or Jen,
and then you wait one hour and you measure your post Prandial insulin.
So after the meal,
and then that value should be about between 12 and 17.
If it's above that,
you could have norming normal morning insulin.
But the problem is,
is that normal morning incident,
he's like having a normal ECG is quite possible that you have a normal ECG at
rest,
but you exercise for 10 seconds and you received g is all over the place,
right?
So,
uh,
an Oregon,
you can only see it's really healthy if you stress it.
Okay.
So when you give a dose and really fast carbohydrates in the morning and you'd
skip insulin goes through the roof,
it means that you don't have a good pantry
pancake,
pancreatic health and your insulin resistance is a rendered.
So I liked that test,
but we found,
for example,
in a lot of physique competitors,
they got great morning,
uh,
glucose and insulin.
But when you can do to reactive test,
they fail miserably.
So,
you know,
so what the,
a lot of things that make them lean is not actually so healthy for them.
So I think the reactive insulin test is the most underrated tests,
uh,
in health.
And how should people select their doctor?
The person that will help them administer these tests?
Because you and I know there's,
there's the good,
the bad and the ugly.
I remember this MD friend of mine said p equals MD and pass equals MD.
And Yeah,
there are a lot of shitty doctors out there.
There are also some great doctors.
But how,
how would you suggest someone find a doctor who can competently administer and
interpret these tests?
I think the best way to find them over the years is that go through a
[inaudible] dot org so it's the American college for advancement of medicine.
It's the college that certifies people do chelation therapy,
uh,
to treat vascular disease.
What I found is that the guys who have an interest for that therapy tend to have
an interest on functional medicine.
So there's a good,
it's a good cross reference.
It's not 100%,
but when I tell my students we're asking the exact same question as you to do
that,
the,
in more than nine out of 10 cases,
they report that they're very happy with that new doctor.
Um,
the thing is,
is that the length of time they spent with you on the first visit is bar you
best indicator.
I find the best doctors out there take about two hours to do a medical history.
Uh,
another way to find a good one is just ask around.
I mean,
when people ask me,
he said,
do you know somebody here?
And I said,
yeah,
I don't know God.
So in most large American cities,
I find some of what,
for example,
recently I had a student of mine from Luxembourg,
uh,
was an MD and I got talking to them and I I realize are way ahead of the curve.
You was.
So there was,
you know,
a lot of students in a classroom,
14 different or European countries and say,
hey,
you guys are looking for a good doctor,
go see him.
And then a female doctor from the Netherlands and she was very open minded and
you know,
she really was looking at different way to treat are patients.
And then I,
so I found somebody in the,
and then so the,
there's a lot of good people,
but the best is to ask around.
But one of the key points is that they don't do a two hour medical history,
uh,
you know,
at the right place.
Yeah.
I know.
This is,
this is,
uh,
I think worth digging into a little bit because,
for instance,
I mean,
one of the red flags for me,
and I'm not a doctor,
don't play one on the Internet,
but I've,
I've broken myself enough and done enough experiments that I've,
I've,
uh,
had a chance to sample a
lot of doctors at the kind of medical buffet.
And,
uh,
whenever I have someone respond very definitively to a single blood test,
I always get very worried.
They,
if they don't ask if I had anything to drink,
if I didn't,
if I did or did not do a workout before the test,
if they don't ask some of those questions,
uh,
and they're simply trying to prescribe some type of medication,
say to address,
uh,
slightly depressed testosterone,
well,
they're,
they're not doing their homework right.
They're not really doing their detective work properly.
Um,
at least that's my preference.
But are there any other kind of red flags or a pet peeves that you would use to
disqualify doctors?
Well,
I would truly agree with you is a classic example.
There's someone that you and I both know,
uh,
sends me an email of freaking out.
He's been diagnosed with cardiovascular disease,
blah,
blah.
And I said,
sending your blood work.
So he sends it to me,
and again,
I'm not a doctor,
but Ashton,
hey,
let me get you ate before the test and he had a 36 set,
12 reps per workout,
uh,
per exercise before you did the test.
And he goes,
how'd you know?
Well,
because of blah,
blah,
blah.
And I said,
that test is not valid.
Redo the test 12 hour fast and then sent to me and I'll find you the right
doctors.
So,
you know,
the point is,
is that the doctor read the test,
told he was going to die.
I said,
no,
because you're biased to test by doing these two stupid things.
And the doctor should have asked you,
did you exercise?
Did you eat before the meal?
Was that,
uh,
you know,
whatever.
So,
um,
it,
I agree with you 100%.
Yeah.
I mean the,
there's some basic questions they should ask to eliminate error.
You know,
one thing that I insist on is that the always do at 12,
exactly 12 hours after the last bite.
Why?
Because they want pre and post measures there are valid because you know,
you could,
you group morning glucose could be all over the place because you fasted and
extra two hours and it's not valid.
Yeah,
totally agree.
And this is,
this is I,
and I don't want to harp on this too much,
but I think it's really important.
So it's worth underscoring for people and that is the,
well let me bitch for a second first and that the,
the same people who would criticize you for not,
uh,
sort of walking a strict line with clinical studies when the same people who
don't pay attention to any of these variables when they're dealing with their
patients directly.
And it's just,
it makes me insane because you have to control these variables.
Like you said,
it can't,
you can't have one blood test six hours after you ate because you had a late
night,
need a burrito after getting shit faced and then the next time do it on a
Wednesday after no drinking after 12 hour fast.
You those that's apples to oranges and you're not going to be able to get any
good data out of that.
Um,
but the,
um,
for,
for people out there,
I mean,
the one thing that I've always asked friends,
because
people come to me just as they are,
your friends come to you and they're like,
oh my God,
I'm freaking out.
My doctor wants to do a,
B,
c,
d,
and e.
And like I said,
everybody just so,
so I don't have to deal with the stupid,
um,
legal issues.
I'm not a doctor,
but what,
what,
what I'll,
well,
I'll ask is I'll say,
when did you take,
what day of the week did you take the last test?
And when did you take this test?
And,
and Lo and behold,
it's almost always like after a shitty three days of of sleep or it's after a
binge drinking for two nights and their testosterone drops 200 points.
And also the blood test was done at say like 10:00 AM instead of 8:00 AM.
And I'm like,
all right,
well
you can't,
you have to have some standardization for these numbers to be meaningful in any
way.
It's
very true because I'll call for example,
I used to train a lot of pro athletes,
but they would add,
let's say a stag party in Vegas.
What's goes on in Vegas stays in Vegas,
but by Monday when he gave blood work,
I could tell they were in Vegas just you know,
and there's things like for example in massage could throw your CPA through the
roof if it was fairly aggressive.
And until I'll say,
well,
you know,
you have a kidney issue or whatever,
they,
their biases.
And for example,
in the liver enzymes,
I get this one all the time.
My liver enzymes are elevated.
So then I tell,
I send this study from Sweden,
people lift weights three days a week of chronically 20% higher than normal
elevations in liver enzymes and it's non pathological.
So essay short out to your doctor before they put you on some liver drug.
You know?
So the thing that always said,
it's not the doctor's fault,
the,
like you said,
p equals MV.
So the thing is is that they're not forced to keep up with the literature.
And we know that the books they study in medical school or only nine years,
our data's,
for example,
if you look at blesses this ominous,
if you look at,
we look at what was that the last dyssomnias one of the intestinal,
a pathogen you,
according to the most recent book in pairs analogy,
it's not bad for you.
You should not be treated.
But this good studies done on Iraq war veterans that show that that,
uh,
intentional pathogen leads to degeneration of eyesight,
but because it blocks the absorption of vitamin A and it also leads to
degeneration of joints.
But there's two good papers are published in 94.
They're not in the book of Prose Otology but so we're looking in 2015 and the
researcher was done any four and it's not even in the current books that medical
students read.
So a lot of people have,
you know,
good and bad eyesight or osteoarthritis from untreated intestinal pathogen.
And then it tells me there's no research on that,
that there is research.
I mean,
one of the most common comment is there's no research that dude did you hear?
He didn't try to look at it.
So
yeah.
And then there's,
for example,
there was some guy on arping on that my doses are losing,
were too high.
There were not backed up by research.
Well the two best research papers on leucine in really hard training people were
done by the same goober researchers in France.
They only publish the results in French.
So I can't blame him for the guy to see.
You didn't read,
you could say,
I didn't read anything on it.
But to say that doesn't exist is lie because it did exist,
you know,
where,
where are your favorite sort of go to sources for doing searches for research?
I mean there's pub bed of course.
Uh,
but,
but um,
w what,
what are sort of your goto top sources?
Actually my top sources pub med.
But the thing is is that you have to learn a few things about how to search.
For example,
she Shandor Berry,
which is a greater,
uh,
to treat,
too much oxidation in the liver.
Right?
Well,
does 88 synonyms for it in the literature,
if you look at,
uh,
only Bazell,
it has so many different names.
So what I use is a proc called the natural,
uh,
database.
And then they give you all the synonyms for each,
uh,
natural compounds.
And then I search under,
uh,
the different ones because for example,
for only Bazell you can find a lot of research,
but the,
the,
um,
it's not,
it's not the,
this is the most commonly used name in English,
but you have to look under the different Indian names for it to find all the
research.
Because a lot of research that clinically on it was done in India or done in
Thailand and it's peer reviewed,
but it only use Oli basles a keyword.
So you know,
you the natural medical database is a good tool for finding out the synonyms if
you're looking at a nutrient,
but the nobody beats pub med in my opinion.
Yeah,
it's,
this is really excellent advice and I just want to kind of reiterate for folks
that you,
you have to search for the synonyms and not only that,
I mean,
so for instance,
you can take like Alpha lipoic acid and then thioctic acid or whatever.
Yeah.
But,
but not only that,
but like you said,
if you have studies being done in say India,
uh,
with ayurvedic medicine,
like what are the herbs that contain a lot of fill in the blank,
right?
So you can find these natural sources,
which then are also sometimes studied,
even if the isolated nutrients aren't studied.
And it sounds like a lot of work,
but it's not,
it's not that time consuming once you just have each step one for the checklist.
There's a great book called the checklist manifesto that I thought,
Oh yeah,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that's one of my favorite books.
Uh,
so good by a tool go on day who's an MD?
And so it's like,
what is your checklist for doing research?
It's like,
okay,
number one,
go to natural database,
find some synonyms,
right?
Then go to a pub med and do this following search.
And then if you've read,
say that a bad medicine,
it's like,
okay,
what filters do I run this through?
What are the five to 10 questions that I ask myself to make sure I don't fool
myself?
Right?
You know,
is this interview,
how was it delivered?
Right?
You can't just take oral dosages and,
uh,
or intravenous dosages and assume that you're gonna get the same effect from
oral consumption.
Right?
A question for you on hormone replacement therapy.
So a lot of,
a lot of people are fascinated by hormone replacement therapy.
Um,
uh,
how have your thoughts on hormone replacement therapy changed or evolved?
Uh,
and,
and we could make it specific to guys,
but we don't have to.
It's a,
well,
I think that there's a stronger place for it than ever before because
you know,
people ask you,
well,
it's not natural,
blah,
blah.
Okay.
All right,
let's go back a second year.
One thing that distinguishes humans from animals is goal setting and progress.
Okay?
So I don't think eagles gather up together in January said,
okay,
this year that's eat 78% more rats and I want to expand.
So the animals that do are animals,
they do what they do,
but we were whoever you want to blame for it.
We're blessed with a brain that can learn a new vault.
And then the reality is is,
and this is the World Health Organization statistics,
just average testosterone level as decreased 1% per year since 1950 so what was
considered good to Starstone levels and an enormous tend to change per country.
So for example,
a Dj sulfate in the UK,
if you have 1.6 to 1.8 it's good if you have 1.9 is considered to have high
elevated androgens.
But in Canada,
the norms are three to 10.
So if you're a British male at 1.9,
you don't exist in the medical alarms and gather,
okay.
So you don't qualify as a male.
Uh,
it may be a male in the UK,
but you know what,
a male in Canada,
so I show the reality is that,
okay,
we,
we've softened up on the norms,
but we should look at optimal versus a normal.
Right?
So with hormone therapy,
one thing I'll also knows who I have a hundred times more stressed than our
grandparents.
Our grandparents didn't have iPhones.
It didn't have to answer 70 emails an hour,
blah,
blah.
So,
uh,
and there's also the radiation,
which is now more and more well documented and all these things,
uh,
suppress testosterone.
So hit I think is viable,
but yet it's like your carbohydrates,
you need to deserve it.
So for example,
I see a lot of kids who go on growth hormone and that they're still making
plenty.
And by doing growth from too early to actually shutting down their production.
Same thing with testosterone,
but the,
the attitude varies a lot from country to country.
For example,
there used to be a drug,
uh,
in France called parabolics,
just trembling.
I forget the uh,
exactly extra.
But if you look in the companion in the 80s,
they would encourage doctors to give the kids who were bullied at school.
Oh my God.
So basically they said yes,
it was different.
Like,
okay,
the kid has a little muscle mass,
low self esteem,
put him on tremble,
know an American doctor that would do that,
would get castrated and sent to jail for 40 years.
Just to put this in perspective for people,
so tremble,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
I'm pretty,
it's hard for a lot of people to come by who are say like worldclass
powerlifters.
So they'll take,
they'll take capsules that are intended to be injected into cattle and basically
in a,
dissolve them into a liquid so they can inject them.
And this was,
this was prescribed to children and are getting bullied.
That
terminal in bodybuilding world,
the profiting rules one of the most potent drugs.
Right.
But the attitude was very different.
It is a friend of mine who's a pharmacist who has actually studied that,
that the concept,
and he said like attitude towards drugs is very different.
For example,
in lot of South American countries,
they think that putting stem cells all and multivitamins for kids is good so
they can gain weight.
But the thing with uh,
HRT,
what,
what I see is that a lot of people jump on a bandwagon because they can make
money in up in church,
you know,
horrendous price with testosterone and then,
which is mixed cost,
$2 a sec to make any charge you $150 a season.
But the,
the,
um,
the therapies that I would say in the US is probably the three guys I know how
to do it properly.
And so if I'm an executive that says to me,
you know,
my testosterone was the same as a Catholic,
a church mouse,
what could I do while I send them to these three dots?
And He'd do a good job.
But they,
the,
uh,
it takes monitoring.
You have to monitor for your estrogens,
you have to align it to your cardiovascular risk factors.
And so on.
Uh,
but if it's done properly,
it's very good.
I think the more exciting real now is actually the use of peptides.
Um,
but the peptides,
it's the,
the frontier right now,
you know,
everybody,
but I've met a guy in Australia recently,
probably has done the most clinical research on it.
And when he explained to me odd to use them is view on how to use them at a time
was diametrically opposite to what the cowboys on your net recommend.
But,
but when I was in the waiting room,
it was the WHO's who have the strength world was waiting for that point.
So obviously he's clinical experience was very good.
And then,
um,
but he was really,
really far ahead.
But for example,
for repairing joints,
you know,
this two peptides are getting lock the,
and he worked very well.
Uh,
now they're just for research purposes,
but I think that HRIT if it's done properly,
it's quite validated as long as you're not in a,
uh,
drug tested sporting.
If you're a 40 year old stockbroker and you have zero sex drive and you've
shaped like a period water ball and yeah,
go get some testosterone therapy because,
but you know,
and I think he said,
I think it's underestimated is the balance between Dha sulfate and the
testosterone.
And I asked to be kept in balance because Dha sulfate is the mother of all
androgens.
And if you don't take care of that at the same time,
he can get into a lot of trouble.
So you elaborate on what because well,
for example,
you know,
every molecule can be linkedin in emotion and really think about,
I mean you just spirit world book on that.
But the sulfate is the molecule,
I think for me of motivation or one of them.
Okay.
And if you take so much tests that you don't have enough Dha sulfate,
you could,
you just a big lug with no drive.
So,
uh,
you asked to keep the dag sulfate.
And also you have to balance that with how much a salivary cortisol you make.
It's not easy.
When you look at hormone therapy,
you can't look at a world tour,
strong Neto age thinking a shitload of testosterone is not going to solve your
problems.
The best guy,
the best educator on HRT is cherry air tog from Belgium.
You'd lectures all over the world.
How do you spell his name?
Charles?
It's he's t,
H I,
e r r y.
And his family names h e r t o gue or t h o l.
G.
U.
E t.
AF tag.
And he's,
um,
I'm glad I asked.
I never would've,
yeah.
But easily found on that he teaches all over the world.
She's probably teaching three weekends out of four always to endocrinologists or
the anti aging circle.
But you know,
you'll talk about,
for example,
of balancing things like,
uh,
oxytocin,
with your testosterone.
So he has a very good approach and,
uh,
he's big on monitoring where you store your body fat,
as it relates to hormones.
Yes.
I mean these books are very expensive,
but they really worth the investment.
But he ill explain,
um,
or hormone deficiencies manifest in physically outward symptoms.
Like what happens when you're jade,
the sort of APP is to you,
if you,
if you have too much.
Gh is what happens to you if you're done enough.
T three,
you too much to t three.
So he is,
he has made a lot of links between physical medicine and endocrinology and
that's why he's very well respected.
Uh,
and I find the best endocrinologist I've studied under him because he has a
very,
um,
Eagle's view of the hormonal system.
It's not like looking at the world through a straw.
Oh yeah.
Your own test air.
Take a gram a test that week.
I can take a ground tests a week and you don't control the estrogen.
Zero bigger tits and barrel Anderson
within a month.
Yeah.
Well I mean all that dimension.
I mean,
your lipid profile is going,
yeah.
Your,
your,
your lipids are not going to look so,
so impressive.
And yet in Naples,
the size of frisbees.
So you know,
and maybe that's one of your goals in life.
I don't know.
But the point is,
is that HRT is a viable tool.
It has to be done properly.
And it's if the guy just comes in and tests your tests and he wants to give you
your prescription run out of there because look a lot of things.
Yeah,
yeah.
No completely aid.
Let me ask you just a random question.
I mean,
I talked about this very openly in the four hour body.
This is something that bugs me.
We can bitch and Moan about the Internet and other time.
But the fact that I wrote an entire s,
I wrote an entire,
I think four or five pages on like anabolics one on one.
And on Wikipedia it says Tim Ferris,
Ed's admits to have used anabolic agents.
And I'm like,
it,
mits is such a weaselly word.
I wrote him back and fucking chapter about it.
So I've used different anabolics uh,
it,
it with medical supervision after surgeries.
And,
um,
one of the,
uh,
I,
I don't know if it's an urban myth or just one of the common beliefs among
athletes is that decker Draplin helps with joint repair,
but I've never been able to come up with a plausible explanation for why
nandrolone versus other things would have that effect.
And I'm just curious if you think that has any validity and if so what the
plausible explanation might be.
Surely there is a paper on that.
Uh,
it's about five years old.
Um,
I dug it on sheet,
pub med,
the
after we do the call and I'm pretty sure I got it in my an email because I
medical doctor asking me a question and not of interest.
I did find the paper this according to the urban legend,
you know,
you have more fluid in a joint which Decaux habs the joint which allows the
cartilage to regenerate,
blah,
blah blah.
But um,
this particular study was on their regeneration of connective tissue in the Di.
They did find a positive influence from,
I think this study was Nander long funnel appropriate need if my memory serves
me right.
But the um,
I mean,
okay,
again,
you have clinical versus anecdotal evidence,
but many old time powerlifters will tell you that when the self administered
[inaudible] own drugs,
they did see a decrease in joint pain.
But I do know there's at least one Swedish study on the benefits of Nandrolone
in the joint health.
Cool.
I'll check it out,
uh,
yet natural.
And it's just also,
I mean,
I've always,
uh,
I guess it's probably a legal issue.
Um,
and,
and just for those people listening are like,
let me run out and buy some nandrolone.
Uh,
the,
the legal side effects of trying to do this stuff on the black market can be,
uh,
just as harsh as the physical side effects of using them improperly.
So caveat emptor,
don't,
uh,
you know,
go find your local meathead and just inject whatever,
um,
you know,
cooking,
cooking oil,
he happens to sell you.
But,
um,
you know,
Nederland I found really interesting just from the standpoint of um,
a romantization and dealing with some of these other issues that you mentioned.
But anyway,
that's a whole separate conversation with,
but on the,
uh,
it's kind of non,
um,
non-drug stand standpoint or from that perspective,
what are approaches that you take?
What are things that you eliminate from your household or try to avoid,
whether that's due to environmental estrogens or you know,
phytoestrogens or whatever the hell is synthetic estrogens or otherwise.
Um,
what,
what are things that you keep trying to keep out of your house or away from your
body?
Well,
the thing is is that there's quite a few estrogens that can inform it,
cosmetics,
shampoos and so on.
So a very simple tool is to go to ewg.org and the rank,
uh,
in quality.
All the common household products,
shampoos,
moisturizers,
or whenever.
If,
so,
for example,
there's one that comes to mind that is given for free and the Canada's biggest
health chain.
It has a five types of para beans and pair of beans is linked to all forms of
cancer.
But he got five eyes and years of pair being in it.
Uh,
I'm not going to name the company,
but it's,
they're very well known company.
So people go get buffed at the gym in Toronto,
you take a shower and went through this dry.
So we've got dry scan,
they put that thing in and then basically lathering on crushed forms of oral
contraceptives.
So,
so,
so I only buy organic,
uh,
certified organic products for body care.
Um,
my actually to my made at the house,
he's very conscious of that stuff.
So she only uses the best product and everything's very far,
ewg.org and it's free.
So,
uh,
and it's high quality,
act to
them in the past.
I think it's a great organization,
but the thing is,
is that
Evelyn distributor,
who actually is the concept of batching,
so I batch my email work at batch when cell phone work.
So I tried to minimize all radiation forms as much as possible.
Um,
over the last three years,
I always take the month of July off and that's when I have time to read stuff on
my upcoming classes.
And three years ago I started to look at their research,
peer reviewed research on them,
electromagnetic pollution.
And it was quite a bit staggering.
A lot of the leading work has been done in France,
but it's not encouraging by any means.
Um,
things like dopamine,
if,
you know what I call Phantom messaged watching is a lot of people will look at
their iPhone for example,
to see if they've got a message.
They don't batch it,
so they are obsessed with,
or they want to see who posted one on Facebook.
They found in Korea that it actually messes up with dopamine receptor site
location.
And it puts people in a state of I per,
um,
the giant ism,
you know,
so they,
they always,
they're basically like a navy seal and middle of Iraq,
uh,
anion Barry tolls on a clothesline with an American flag on their back,
you know,
so they always ready for battle and there's no need for it.
So,
uh,
I fell in the best ways to actually manage stress,
which I learned from the four hour week,
was to batch my emails,
batch my cell phone,
uh,
work.
And I found it's a great stress reducer.
And of course,
biggest added benefit is you're far more productive,
you know,
um,
the,
the food,
the quality of the food,
you could say I'm quite,
uh,
enthusiastic about,
so you know,
where you put in your mouth is a stressor.
And when you say that comes out of your mouth is also a stressor.
So at least you have control on both.
So when I'm here in the US,
it's very easy for me to have the best food.
But when I travel overseas,
actually where I teach is dictated by the quality of the food.
So for example,
I partnered up Nick Mitchell for his ultimate performance gym and Marvea he
goes,
hey,
I don't mind sunshine.
I'd rather teach than sunshine.
So I do most of my European seminars now,
Spain.
But in Spain I found this guy,
uh,
Michael and Antonio who finds me boar and deer and you know,
and the quality of the fish is very good.
So if I teach six weeks in Spain,
I got the best food.
Uh,
if I teach in northern Europe,
I'll either go to Denmark or Sweden,
the same thing cause it's basically good quality.
But in England it is a challenge but still feasible.
If it is,
you have educated enough students that they have dug out the best places.
You know,
even when I was in Manchester,
uh,
two weeks ago I could find some good food.
So it's um,
the Europeans are catching on quicker to this and the southwest the US.
So for example,
if you go to Phoenix,
it's be easier eat organic ego to Rhode Island or Boston.
He should all luck.
When you think of that,
the typical gym in the u s let's just say what,
what drives you nuts about warm ups?
What are people doing incorrectly for warm ups,
for weight training?
Uh,
the foam roller,
that is such a waste until I,
and plus it leads to more scar tissue.
So I only like the foam roller to distract vertebraes that's about it.
Um,
their warm ups.
Okay.
It's very good at evidence by Magda Adis.
But warming up on a treadmill or using the treadmill precipitates insulin
resistance by 46%.
So all it a try and cardio equipment,
in my opinion,
should be banned.
So I see it tomorrow.
You name me emperor of all galaxies and I've got all the power.
I would take all that cardio stuff throughout the gym.
Uh,
I would just replace it with a strong man equipment.
the also the concept of train your core using unstable surfaces.
If you look at the actual research,
we'll find a that Elser about six weeks.
But after that,
there's no added benefit and the best way to strengthen your core competence.
Slowly squats,
dead lifts,
Chin ups,
the ups and so on.
So,
uh,
what drives me crazy is the gyms where I go and everything is done.
Like you'll see a,
a woman do a on a Bosu ball on one leg doing a control,
lateral dumbbell curl and switch legs and arms.
You know,
what does that do?
Fuck all
you know,
you should be better learning how to squat properly and through a set of 20 to
exhaustion.
It,
bring it more heat shock proteins,
which are,
have been associated with a fat loss and muscle building.
So the,
the,
this actually,
uh,
at trend now there's two gym chains around the world that have iron me to
develop educational seminars to get rid of all those balances.
One of them that these see education as a student of mine and he just won a
bodybuilding contest.
It's changed completely.
And even now,
the owners of the change by Whoa,
you know,
what changes did you make these illustrated to do strength training?
And um,
so,
and then one of the biggest chains in England,
I was also asking you to revamp that system because the rule is,
it's like the basics are the basics and you can't beat the basics.
And uh,
Mass Bay first mentor told me there's three rules of success in strength
training.
One is art work to his hard work.
Three is hard work,
so you can't replace quality hard work,
you know?
And if so,
if you were designing the perfect warm up routine,
so you're able to throw the Bosu balls in the dumpster and we'll be able to get
rid of all of the cardio equipment.
Uh,
and let's just for the sake of simplicity,
say someone,
and you can tear this apart,
but just because people have heard of it,
I'll say,
if somebody is getting ready for like a five by five squat workout,
let's just say,
what would you have them do?
Any particular type of warmup?
The perfect word.
Yeah,
of course.
Because there's two rules about warming up.
The brain should know what the range of motion is and to,
their weight's going to get heavier.
So,
so for example,
you want to do five by five at a 100 kilos at 220 pounds.
So you go to the gym if it's squat well,
it's a lot of research that shows that mobility in the ankle is what decreases
the probability of any lower extremity injuries,
whether it's ACL tear or Amsterdam pool or grumpy or whatever.
So the first thing I would do is I would go on a calf machine and stretched the
calves,
uh,
and then go down all the,
statically the stretch for eight seconds.
Then I finish off with a voluntary contraction because it resets,
uh,
the patent owner,
for strength research is clear.
If you do static stretching,
you don't finish what a contraction,
you're more likely to get injured.
So you do the eight second stretch,
let's just say at the bottom of the calf machine,
and then you would go up to sort of a peak holds or is it,
yeah,
he could concentrate on,
on lifting the weight,
actively contracting,
uh,
the calf.
So the way it should be enough to stretch you.
If it's heavy enough to stretch you,
you won't be all lifted,
but you should do a voluntary contraction for two seconds at the end of the
stretch to reactivate the power and your muscle.
So I would make my ankles flexible.
Then I would take the bar and depending on which muscles are tight,
if it's squad or hamstrings or whatever,
I would do the same principle and get into a position where had to basically do
PNF stretching,
right?
And then,
uh,
do those exercises then and mobile for the range of motion.
If the goal is hundred kilos for five sets of five,
then the first one I'm upset we'd be the bar,
just a bar,
four reps,
then I would go to 60 kilos,
which is percent.
So my body knows what the range of motion has done.
I put 60 kilos or 60%.
I would only do about three reps.
Then I would go to 75 kilos.
I would do two raps.
I go there,
uh,
85 kilos,
do one rep 90 kilos,
do one rep,
95 kilos,
do one rep.
So all those weights just telling me to wait,
it's going to be coming soon.
And then squat aren't kilos versus a five.
So I have accomplished my goal.
I know what the range of motion is,
which allows me to have great mechanics and then a,
um,
a more warmed up psychologically and physiologically speaking to handle the
weight.
Some people do what were they called?
Over warm up.
So if they want to train at a hundred,
they'll do a set [inaudible] 95,
then they go to one 10 to activate the nervous system,
but the only one rep,
so they don't really go to fairly,
they just tell the body,
hey,
a hundred kilos going to feel lighter.
The Re,
uh,
Paul Carter is a big advocate of this,
but the first time I'd read it was from,
uh,
a part of the coach in 1973.
I mean,
that's when the article was published,
but it was from Finland and they have a name in it and finish,
which has about 96 letters.
But it means it means proper appropriate reception set.
Um,
so see,
yeah,
appropriate assumptions that,
okay,
so big insurance p set,
but that's a way to warm up,
uh,
where you grew up all over the set.
I mean,
and it's the one thing Paul Carter figured it out by himself,
but
there's such a thing as universal and intelligence.
There's nothing new really.
So,
you know,
I could find in 73 and that's all the research I did on,
but maybe somebody figured it out in 1908 by himself.
I mean in my house here,
I've got everything that's ever been waiting on weight training since 1896
multiple languages.
Like for example,
a Frit,
frittery,
Gill Ids,
anatomy books.
I've got them in 15 different languages.
So I find it's a good way,
you know,
I love learning languages,
but you should learn things you're passionate about.
So you know,
after that you can learn a lot of grammar on explaining somebody ought to squat.
He learned that erections and whatever.
So I,
uh,
I've used that as a tool for learning languages.
But the point is,
is that when people say,
Oh,
I've invented this,
I said,
bullshit.
It was in men in Egypt,
1923 or 1908 by Bob people or whatever it is,
the,
what's newest combinations,
um,
you know,
or applications.
But like a fad grip dumbbells is not new.
I mean that's 1896.
So,
um,
what I did for the Fed grip dumbbells,
I made them revolve so the easier on your joints.
So I designed them for uh,
Watson gym equipment.
They're calibrated,
their nuclear attack resistant,
blah,
blah.
But all I did is it's um,
eh ameliorations yeah,
right.
New Application of an old idea.
Yes,
yes.
But there's nothing new and we train
to,
speaking of the squat routine that you sort of led up to,
what are the most common mistakes that people make after they finished their
work sets or,
or after a workout for that matter
and the really,
really big Bailey Tim in immediate recovery,
that's from personal experience.
Okay.
I mean that the summer research from Australia and South Africa back or two
years is cortisol used to be considered the enemy.
Now in the last four years,
we figured out that the more cortisol you make drink training,
the greater training response.
So people used to take cortisol blockers before training that stupid Gleason no
gains.
But I think that the effect of the Cortisol is transitory.
So you induce the message,
then you got to get rid of the message.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you know,
as,
uh,
what's that guy?
Uh,
Charlie Sheen.
I don't pay women to have sex.
I paid him to leave after sex.
So of course I was like that.
It's like the prostitute,
you got to get rid of the,
of the prostitutes that you've got to get rid of it.
So I know my analogies it up there,
but people like graphic stuff,
so they remember far better.
So you want to get rid of cortisol.
So in my opinion is you got to suppress cortisol immediately after exercise.
Um,
of course,
you know,
people say when she been handed down that hey,
I don't think my,
listen 17 disparate sports,
that's my dad.
So I've tried not to do it and I,
you know,
I,
I've gone away from it after I different ways,
but I really believe you've got to bring that cortisol down.
The best way to do that is to make yourself more insulin sensitive.
So you do,
you go through your steps to make yourself incidences there,
but it's somebody who trains really hard.
Let's say he weighs 200 pounds or we like to have a 200 grams of carbohydrate
blend right after each.
What about 50 grams of high quality protein?
A lot of people are intolerant to weigh and they don't even know.
I really like essential amnio acid blends.
So if you're a 200 pound man,
I developed a product for ATP lab and the cat,
it's called Panther car cyclodextrins some dextrose in three forms of non GMO
Maltodextrin.
I give that to people with uh,
about 50 grams of essential aminos in most cases if they can handle the whey
protein,
I give him the whey protein because it's way cheaper.
Or sometimes I give them go away because they're not to go away,
but he may be intolerant to cows week.
Where does someone find goat?
Where just out of curiosity,
I mean,
I make no money telling you this,
but my fear brand is Tiaras.
Wait,
Apostrophe S.
Wait,
you can find it all foods,
but on Amazon they'll split your asked to shifty within 24 hours.
Uh,
that's,
that's where,
that's where I get mine.
Um,
and it's,
I find it personally to be more in a buck and a causeway.
That's my personal preference.
But I use for my immuno acids,
one of my students,
other Germany makes.
Uh,
and when I said Slash Electric Wade complex,
and I use that,
I mean,
it's something I never ran out.
It's a,
uh,
come back from a trip.
I put two canisters back into my luggage.
I don't want to forget it.
So,
and with,
with say the Penta Carb,
just so people don't,
uh,
take,
take the,
the wrong or interpreted the wrong way.
At what point have you earned that?
Say,
you know,
200 grams of carbohydrates,
50 grams of protein,
for instance,
if you're a larger athlete,
because I know that,
I'm sure you've seen it.
I've seen it.
I go to the gym,
I see somebody do 10 minutes on an elliptical while watching part of a game of
Thrones.
They get off of them.
They,
they drink 500 calories of carbohydrates at when?
When does it make sense to consume this post,
this post workout and when does it not make sense?
Yes,
yes,
it deserve your cards and I'll repeat myself on that and dessert or done any
carbs for six days.
You need to be sub 10 cent body fat.
And the quickest way to know if you have slept in body fat as a male is can I
see the Linea Alba and your apps and or we're just going to see all Ambrose one
add row doesn't count if you try to see them all.
Okay,
so you have to have penis skin on your abs.
If you get pitch an inch,
it certainly all deserve carbohydrates.
So you know,
if you could see visibly your abs,
then that's when you deserve it.
Until then I said I think you should stick to uh,
either way or essential amino acids and more branch chains and some glutamine
because you don't deserve it.
But
one of the things that increases our balls and Mr be insulin sensitive.
What makes you insulin sensitive?
Losing body fat.
I mean,
Nick Mitchell send me some pictures yesterday of this,
uh,
journalists that he's training and this guy looked at a human for Aiga and in
nine weeks that guy's got abs,
right?
I mean,
he was considering calling his book author Polish a Turd.
But
no kidding.
But the thing is,
is that he took this guy who horrendous and it's all documented.
So there's no like Photoshop and bullshit and took him from it.
I would estimate at 23% body fat or 9% body fat in nine weeks.
What did he do?
He restricted this cards.
So now that he's lean,
he's jacked up this card.
So you've got to deserve your cards,
but if you don't deserve it,
don't have them.
It just get fatter.
What,
um,
what are some commonly neglected ways to decrease body fat aside from
restricting carbohydrates?
I think that the biggest mistake is to do steady state cardio.
You want to get fatter?
Go right ahead.
Uh,
the second most biggest mistake is to use the low fat approach.
So some people will restrict their carbohydrates,
but they restrict their fats too.
So that's a big mistake.
If you're going to go high protein,
low carb,
you need to have high fat.
So you cook your meats in olive oil and butter,
you put butter on your vegetables and so on and you take coconut oil and uh,
that would help you,
uh,
get more insulin sensitive.
The thing too is decreasing cortisol.
Cortisol is a great enemy when we are talking about developing insulin
resistance.
Are you the Oud?
You decrease cortisol.
Well,
you manage your stress.
How do you manage your stress?
Well,
you get an effective work habits.
You eliminate distractions.
When you're at work,
turn off your email,
only answer your email right before lunch and right before you leave work.
I mean,
there's a lot of ways to manage your stress.
One of books I really like and I recommend to all my students,
it's 59 seconds from Richard Wiseman.
Oh,
I've never heard of it.
Okay.
It to him,
he got to read that book.
It,
I would say it's one of those best book you'll ever read because what he does,
he takes a critical look.
Yeah.
At the self help industry and one that tests he makes you do.
He describes 10 self help techniques that are repeated over and over,
uh,
in the self help literature.
And he asks you to identify which ones work.
I won't tell you the answer but I am 100%,
uh,
on the test because I was that identify the ones that don't work and the ones
that do work.
So for example,
one of the common ones that you read and every book,
imagine the body that you want black,
you know,
that's,
well all he does is encourage you to be delusional.
What works is a plant would an action step.
You want to get lean,
you need a plan.
If you fail to plan,
you plan to fail.
So,
and in the book,
what he does it,
you answered a challenge from his friend Sophie.
Sophie said,
Mbg,
I want to help myself but I want stuff that is science based and I want to not
take a lot of time.
So he says,
so I can give you an asset in under one minute.
She goes,
right.
So
that's why the book is called 59 seconds.
And in the book you go over anything from building relationships to a goal
setting,
any destroys a lot of myths about goal setting and he's bullshit studies.
They were never actually done and,
but he does everything.
Uh,
so you would love it and you'll talk about anything from increasing your high,
your odds to getting picked up when your child through whatever.
It's very,
very funny guy and he's written a lot of very good books.
Uh,
he's the one who wrote core ecology.
he's a magician.
He says being a phd in psychology and he could see his magic tricks on Youtube
is pretty interesting guy.
He's um,
so like that,
that's probably the best self help book.
But I tell people,
if you really want to change to read that book,
I'm 59 seconds.
You have a Richard Wiseman.
Very cool.
What's,
um,
what other books do you gift the most other people or recommend the most?
I get that one often.
The only one I read like to give is the one thing.
I'm actually lecturing with one of the authors in Texas,
uh,
in November.
So if you want to join up it,
just go look at,
um,
the,
uh,
powerful executive.com.
It'll be a page with all three registered,
but,
uh,
Jay Papasan wrote the one thing with Gary Keller.
Um,
Eh,
it's very similar actually the four work week and a lot of points,
I mean,
successor was a success rules,
right?
Uh,
but when I read your book and I tell my students to buy your book,
what I learned from you was that work way too hard.
And I had no fun in my life.
So,
so after reading your book and Jay Papasan and Gary Keller,
recommend the first thing you should plan in a year as your vacation.
So African reading,
both of these books,
I mean,
when I'm at home,
I worked two and a half to four hours Max.
I think the month of July off at take the first two weeks of August off.
I don't work the month of December until about end of January and a week a month
I take off.
Okay.
And they're in that in my life unless until the last four years.
But what else would the one thing is that you have to pick one activity per day
that will change the rest of your life.
So for example,
doing a podcast with you is my one thing today because you're very popular
author.
I mean short who's another one of my heroes was a on your podcast recently.
Uh,
actually Arnold Schwarzenegger,
he is probably the most inspiring man you could listen to.
I was very fortunate to be invited by Tony Doherty to teach of the Arnold
classic last March in Australia.
And on the Sunday morning there was a small group of us.
Uh,
we're invited to listen to Arnold Schwarzenegger and coming out of the bed
lectured.
I don't think in my life ever been that fired up.
What I like about Schwarzenegger,
he's very honest.
And the thing he talked the most about it was actually his mistakes.
And,
uh,
you know,
it takes balls to do that and I'm all,
you learn from them and so on.
So the,
uh,
but the one thing is one of my favorite books,
I tell him about students because it gets you organized and makes you focused,
um,
a success.
The rules are universal,
you know?
No,
it's just like strength training.
Like you said.
I think there,
there are old ideas and new applications.
And,
uh,
I remember I was on the BBC once and is,
it was kind of funny because I knew that they were going to set me up.
Uh,
they were,
it was a,
it was a segment on self help.
And I was like,
okay,
well if it's,
if they're calling itself help,
this is going to be an attack piece.
And I knew it,
I knew it was coming.
So I sat down and they were like,
so Mr Ferris,
you know,
and they said this in the,
in the most British way imaginable.
I mean,
it was very polite but very condescending.
Not all British people are,
are like that,
but it is a super power in the UK.
And um,
and they said,
uh,
so how would you defend people in the self help genre who this,
this and this?
And I said,
I wouldn't,
I think they're full of shit.
I said,
I think that for the most part,
you know,
you should only take advice from people who have a track record of implementing
that same advice.
And,
uh,
you know,
if I identify more with,
uh,
or if,
if,
if you ask me who my favorite self help author is,
I'd probably say Ben Franklin,
right?
I mean,
that's right.
I'm looking back or Seneca maybe,
you know?
Yeah.
Really rewind the clock.
And I think that the one thing,
uh,
is,
is just the title itself after you've read the book I think is very helpful
because whether you look at Seneca,
you look at some of the top performing CEOs in Silicon Valley,
you've actually have lives outside of the businesses they're building.
They're constantly asking a question that is some variants of like,
what is the one thing on this list that really matters,
right?
What is the one thing on this list that will make all the other things easier,
unimportant,
or whatever.
Right?
There's,
there's always some variation of that question.
Correct.
And it's,
um,
but I,
I think it's,
it's so valuable for people to hear you say what you did,
which is your planning vacation first rate.
You're blocking out times for the fun things.
Because if you don't do that,
then work,
we'll simply swell to fill those times and fill those voids.
What do you do with your,
uh,
when you take,
say the month off,
what are the,
what are the things that you now do?
Well,
it give you an example.
My daughter loves martial arts.
And last two summers we went to Sweden,
Stockholm,
and she trained with this,
a Sensei in Brazilian Jujitsu.
And so she trained three times a day,
twice,
a twice in Jujitsu,
once in lifting.
And,
but in between,
we would do,
uh,
things like visit biking museums.
We would do some type of touristic learning experience,
right?
And we'd go off,
uh,
visit the islands of Stockholm for one day,
whatever that is.
I think that,
you know,
when I'm raising her,
I tried to make your visit as many countries as possible every year so that she
doesn't,
you know,
80% of 15 year old Americans can't put the US on the world map.
That's,
that's a big issue.
So,
you know,
by going here,
there and then every day ask your three questions and you know,
I always ask her and I've been in action.
She's a toddler,
she could speak is one is what have you done today to help someone?
And then she'll say whatever.
And then the second question is always what someone than knife for you today or
to help you out.
And then the third question is always,
what did you learn?
And then,
you know,
so one time we went to visit a lady where we're in London,
who's an expert on mammals.
She wrote a book on mammals that my daughter read when she was five or six years
old.
And so I booked a brain picking fee with a lady.
She,
she was kind of puzzled why we're going to do that.
And I asked my daughters,
get asked her what her,
uh,
you want about animals and then she act know,
and the lady was surprised how much my daughter knew about things that are now
smart.
The question is work,
but you know,
a life not examined is not a word,
a life worth living.
So I think it's really important that you pause at the end of the day to she
would have you done.
And you know,
I religiously,
uh,
donate 10% of what I make,
the different causes.
So for example,
on the weekend that adopted an enter tiger and uh,
this afternoon,
Lorie hang up and making a donation to the navy seal foundation.
So it's really important that w and one of the principles in life,
if you want to be successful,
these to give what you want.
So if you give away money,
you'll receive money.
Uh,
if you,
so if you're not willing to give it away,
you won't attract it and on it sounds a bit of all key,
but it's very true.
And my father taught me that a long time ago.
You had the same practice,
but I remember in university adding zero money.
I mean I was so poor to furniture was painted on the walls,
you know.
So I uh,
I donated 150 bucks,
50 bucks left in my account after that to a,
a homeless people shelter.
And the next day I sold one main university papers to two different federations
and each pay me one,
pay me 600 bucks and he had a one pay me 1200 bucks for the same chapter is a
chapter on training for vertical jump and volleyball.
But so the return on investment was immediate.
But I'm a big believer if you want more money,
give more weight and uh,
you know,
we first have a why the navy seal foundation or those guys take care of that.
We can live the way we want to live,
but our government doesn't support them very well once the abused them.
Right.
So I leave clear instructions that I want them to the money to be used for
react.
A lot of guys get injuries and the one that takes care of them,
right.
But it doesn't matter if you give to doctors without borders or,
or whatever else.
I mean,
the thing is that if you leave this planet with are making it better than them,
you were born,
you didn't live a good life.
Yeah.
What's the point?
Agreed.
Uh,
the,
um,
when you,
what are questions that you ask yourself at the end of the day or the end of the
week,
just like you had the questions that your daughter asks,
uh,
or that you asked your daughter rather,
are there,
are there questions that you revisit on a regular basis?
Well,
it's,
how can I make this better?
Or,
oh,
can it make the teaching more effective?
You know,
I realized over the years that you act to simplify more and more and more and
more.
If there's,
one thing I've learned was for 54 years on earth is that,
uh,
as Einstein said,
there's genius in simplicity.
Yeah.
And one thing I've,
I've always admired about the way you teach.
Also,
we'll look.
Two things really that I've observed.
Uh,
number one is you use metaphor and analogy in a very memorable way.
And a,
I mean,
people,
if I asked them what the Charlie Sheen point was,
is there going to remember cortisol?
And it's,
but it's,
it's funny.
Yes.
And it's a,
it,
it's very Charles.
Yes.
But it's,
it's also memorable and I think that,
uh,
you know,
simplifying and pegging these concepts to memorable imagery is something you're
very gifted at.
Um,
and you're also not,
uh,
you're not overly easy on your students,
which I appreciate because for instance,
I'm training with this,
uh,
this,
this older Polish trainer in his sixties.
And I've,
I've,
I've generally not worked with trainers on a regular basis.
I've worked with coaches,
but now I suppose he could be considered a coach.
And we're working on,
he has four world records and Olympic weightlifting.
And He,
the first time I met him,
he,
he's like,
take off your shirt.
And he walked over and just kind of pinched my left tit and said,
you're too fat.
And that was the first thing he said to me.
And,
uh,
it was really refreshing because in the u s uh,
we have adopted and developed this,
you know,
you get a gold ribbon for 18th place type of culture,
which is ultimately I think,
a disservice to the students we're trying to help.
Uh,
so it was very refreshing in the end.
He's,
I mean,
he,
he's not always belligerent just for the sake of being belligerent,
but he's very brusque when it serves a purpose.
And,
um,
uh,
I'd love to just hear from you what you think,
what are common mistakes that teachers make aside from not simplifying
something?
Uh,
enough?
I think they're all purpose.
What I do is based on a Japanese concept,
you only a good teacher.
If you leave a student,
it's better than yours.
So I always try to make somebody better than me,
you know,
and I've had many students over the years and I got a few up there now that I
could say I'm starting to get API with.
But one thing where people are successful and you never hear it.
So that's what the senior sales between the eagles,
the Eagle won't fix new goals every year or so.
Um,
and I am what makes me real,
Tim is when I see somebody who they want to say his first world champion in
Jujitsu or another Mellison Kayak or are there other day I was in Stuttgart and
some Dutch student brought the equivalent that Dutch tradition of men's health
or men's fitness.
And they were talking about one of my Dutch students,
we train an Olympic medalist in rent and a guy gave me credit for that.
Uh,
which was nice to see in a foreign language,
you know,
that,
uh,
my name gets out there.
But you know,
my,
my ultimate goal is to have one of my students meet my records of uh,
Olympians and world record holders.
I mean,
next year we have the Olympics in Rio and I'm training girls in wrestling and
I've never had Olympic medalists in wrestling.
So there would be 18 sports.
I found that you,
even though I teach on strength training almost every day,
you still have to keep your finger in the pie because you know,
so with the uh,
the three girls I coach,
I'm really applying my newer transmitter theory and all of them.
But again,
what about mindset?
We're in Cuba.
Each one of my girls won the gold medal.
Okay.
Uh,
and very definite the winds.
But the interesting thing is that they,
as soon as they get off the mat,
within two minutes,
they were sitting beside me asking me to evaluate what I thought they did right
or wrong and what could I infer from their fighting into their strength training
program design.
So there was,
for example,
you don't know,
and I said,
you know what?
Your risks are way too weak.
I said,
so we're going to work on your wrist.
And then Atlanta my rules,
I said,
your lower back is too weak.
She goes like he did he say that I said that when you move up and down is a way
to slow in order back his weekend and this other girl we would Vicky acid,
you need to do a more slow strength.
Your power is very good,
but we need more.
So strength,
which is w I rarely have to say that,
but in your case,
yes,
that's the one that's a mango,
some PCP.
So,
so,
so the,
the,
the point was that,
uh,
people who are winners always have a growth mindset.
And I,
you know,
I remember in 88 my first day with national ski team and I said,
after one workout,
I pointed out to one girl and I said,
you know,
she'll be really good one day.
And they all looked at me like,
what the hell do you know about Alpine skiing?
It says she'll,
she won't make it more than one year.
She was 15 at the time.
It was a very young,
during national team.
And in 1994 she was three.
She was world champion.
What did you see in her?
What did you notice at what I call the growth mindset in a sense that she can
after your workout and,
oh,
can I do this?
What can I do?
So I find that my best athletes,
nothing that I see and it's hard to measure your art to explain.
Um,
Richburg talked about,
he called it the intangible is that it's the attitude while you're doing a set.
One of my all time favorites was a grilling Karen Percy.
She won a bronze at the Olympics in two silver,
uh,
two silvers or the wheels or a silver hundred Bronson like that.
But she could be friendly with her teammates in between sets.
But when she picked up the bar,
she was on some other galaxy.
You could tell by her eyes that she was just doing the set,
but there was nothing you could have let off a hand grenade beside her.
She wouldn't have been jumped and look at all the guys have coach or ladies have
coaching,
move won Olympic medals.
They all have that,
you know,
fifth dimension look.
Teleportation ability.
Yes,
because they,
they live in a moment and they are absorbed in what they do and there's nothing
that will disturb them.
Just going to say,
you mentioned these female wrestlers and a couple of questions came from fans of
mine about training a female clients.
And I'd be curious to hear what you think the perhaps biggest mistakes that are
made by trainers who train women or uh,
just the,
the biggest mistakes that say women make if they're training,
not necessarily to win an Olympic gold medal,
but just for the usual set of goals,
right.
To lose fat,
to look a bit better,
to be a bit stronger.
Um,
and uh,
I'll follow up with some,
uh,
some other questions related to athletic goals,
but what are some of the mistakes in your mind that you see most frequently with
the trainers?
With female clients?
I would say the biggest mistake is not wanting to get strong,
you know,
the
getting strong.
Does it make you a bad person?
So the f I would say from the outside,
if I were to criticize the industry or give a fair evaluation,
there's not enough time spent on overload with women,
you know,
in a sense that they don't have goals to for strength.
So you know,
they should have shorter goals to comply to you because you know what,
it's a dead lift or you look at one of my top students,
her name is Kelly Martinovich,
she's other Perth,
Australia.
You go to Virginia.
Do you really impressed with the quality of the physique of people that we're
going to?
Opo Mines or dental assistants,
all the female,
she trains are in great shape and he could be like seven years old.
Uh,
but,
uh,
one of my students,
Jess and Sydney,
she has a lady that's over 80 and this woman is dead lifting,
you know,
some pretty big,
you wage a good form and there's no excuses.
So I find that where women lack the most is guidance to how to get strong or
the,
or being sold and they barely to get strong because,
uh,
in body composition you need to build lean tissue.
When it be linked tissue,
you're more insulin sensitive,
the more insulin sensitive they are,
the easier it is to burn fat,
blah,
blah blah.
So,
uh,
what I don't like is what I call entered training.
So they keep the people happy and busy,
but busy doesn't mean productive.
Okay.
So I like people to have productive outcome.
Um,
one thing that has helped the industry tremendously actually is crossfit.
And that,
that was actually the next question was sort of the uh,
what you,
what you take from crossfit that's good.
Bad or in between.
Okay.
People think I'm anti crossfit for some unjust reason,
but I think crossfit w what a,
I'll tell you what I like about what the work hard,
do the work smart and not so much,
but you do work hard.
So the intention is there.
Okay.
So,
uh,
one of the is a very good on Gary and provert.
If you only got one asks,
you can't sit on two horses.
So,
so the,
the problem in most crossfit boxes is they trying to accomplish too many things.
Like I said,
simple is better.
And you know,
those guys with the crossfit games,
and I know for a fact they're trained by good strength coaches,
but to comply with politics,
they say doody w o WOD to workout of the day,
which is complete bullshit because I've done consulting for those coaches on to
train for crossfit event.
So for example,
cough,
uh,
my core lecture in Ceres does very well at,
across as games,
but you certainly doesn't do the workout of the day to get there.
So the,
so the intention is good.
They use basic,
simple result producing exercise that I like.
Where I don't like is that there's an oral screening before people come in.
So where did they don't do is that they'll look at people's orthopedic issues.
So if I were again emperor of all galaxies and you wanted to crossfit license,
people should be screened or if they're repeatedly,
and then usually within eight to 12 weeks you can straighten out somebody and
then they can do crossfit.
But I find the best crossfit boxes are all in Scandinavia.
Uh,
they tend to do a more intelligent approach to that.
And then the military and I have been all over the world teaching and he's,
he's been a lot of crossfit boxes and asked him some questions.
He says,
yeah,
Denmark,
Sweden,
Norway.
They tend to do a better job.
And why do you think that is?
I think that it's just as to do an education.
The trainers are there,
are better educated.
And the third thing I like about crossfit is that there's,
they're big to the Palio eating.
Uh,
so they're more conscious about the nutrition.
You go to planet fitness,
there's chocolate milk and pizza night on Friday.
Right?
But like what the fuck's the point?
Where do you want to be pro inflammatory foods?
So,
um,
so,
so the,
the way to make crossfit better is actually,
for example,
there's an accident where a guy severe,
this is fine with us.
It was,
I think he was performing snatch,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
one of the first thing that we're learning that was taught was how to get out of
trouble.
So they say if the bar she feel it goes like this,
get rid of it by,
that'd be an it backwards or forwards.
And you jump accordingly depending on the direction and the bar,
while obviously someone didn't teach him that because you made a rookie mistake
by dropping it improperly.
Um,
so,
you know,
the Olympic lifts are complicated things and to do Olympic lifts for repetitions
is utterly stupid.
So I don't believe in that.
Uh,
my colleague clock off office a bit less diplomatic.
A knee if you can believe that.
What does cluck offs is that his last name?
His first name,
last name.
Give me the clock off the clock off.
We're talking about the guy with the thunder thighs.
I mean,
an incredible actor.
Dimitri is amazing.
Okay.
I didn't realize you were a co lecturing with them.
That's incredible.
Yeah,
I did a and doing another tour with them.
We're going to Toronto,
Las Vegas and four places in Australia,
but I teach with them and we split the days.
But you'll say something new.
She's deep equal American crossfit bullshit and
you know,
yeah.
Educates.
But all the crossfit attendees love him because he's got solutions to crossfit
problems.
Um,
the thing with Dimitri,
I love lecturing with him because he will make sure that 100% of the students
learn,
they'll go to every single person.
And I've been in this business 38 years and they're at some of the stuff,
you show him how to learn the next size.
And they were seeing,
so the Soviet approach,
they don't like to teach you by talking the teach you by what the infringer
called AIDS gets stiff.
So educational exercise,
so it won't say put your hips forward in making,
do an exercise to make your hips go forward or if you,
uh,
so all,
all corrections are done to a specific exercise,
which corrects a technical mistake.
So there's very little talking.
It,
a lot of it is,
is about kinesthetic learning.
Uh,
I really liked that.
No,
just to,
to add to that,
um,
and I haven't had a lot of experience with the eastern European strength
coaches,
but the,
uh,
the Polish gent that I'm working with right now is exactly the same way.
You know,
I asked him his opinion,
I won't mention names,
but of a very famous woman who teaches posture improving posture.
And he said,
well,
I think it's bullshit because you can't just tell someone to improve their
posture.
You have to take them through movements that forced them to prove their posture.
And uh,
it's,
uh,
it's been really fascinating to work with them because like you said,
it's,
it's very light on words,
but a high on sort of progressive exercises.
Um,
what are some of the crossfit problems that to be true has helped athletes,
uh,
fix for themselves?
Well,
when you take the seminar,
the first thing,
the way he does it is that I teach in morning.
All right,
some stuff and I'll tell you what he does.
He shows up and he works out.
He does one or two exercise in front of everybody.
But this guy is amazing.
I was in Montreal.
It was the day after he landed from Moscow.
So he was supposed to be jet lagged.
You slept in the van,
20 minutes of the 40 minute ride,
didn't drink water,
didn't drink coffee,
didn't have breakfast.
You shows up six warm upset,
he takes 180 kilos,
396 pounds.
Power cleans it and push presses twice.
Okay.
And just so people can imagine this,
Dimitri does not look like,
uh,
he,
he's not a big fat power lifter.
Um,
this guy looks like Hercules.
He is not it remotely.
I mean,
what do you think his body fat has to be?
I mean it,
well it's about 6%,
but yeah,
right now you wait 218 kilos and it's about six feet tall.
So he's about to 60 at six feet.
I mean,
you could see his pancreas make insulin when you as a pizza.
So,
but
I mean,
there's a lot of funny stuff.
Like we were in a restaurant,
Montreal
and the grill goes,
sir,
what would you like to drink?
He goes,
I want to cock like cook.
So I said,
in French,
no you mustn't Coca Cola.
And of course Paul Carter was there.
He didn't want to be left out.
So when the girl asking,
what would you like to drink?
So he sees a cock,
but you know,
so we had the correct as English a bit,
but it's a lot better now.
And they are seen a freak,
uh,
every day that he teaches it is 95%,
200% of the world record as like the first demonstration.
Then then we break for lunch,
then I teach mobility for the Olympic lifts.
And then Dimitri,
we'll save,
for example,
the first day will be snatched and he'll go all these progressions.
So the crossfitter we'll know on Friday out of snatch properly.
And,
and he,
he says,
if you don't do PB,
no dinner for you.
So that is where clients that every asked to do with PB,
then it makes it,
yeah,
the next day you'll do some of freak lift,
then you'll teach clean jerk at all.
So I teach art to get flexible from the claim check because a lot of people do
the exercise,
but they shouldn't,
they don't deserve to do it.
So as shown on about an hour and a half,
I'll to be dessert,
uh,
deserve to clincher.
And on Sundays he teaches them out of squat.
He teaches a bunch of different,
uh,
corrective lists,
um,
and you know,
the,
the work their butts off,
uh,
with them.
But the big ones,
the crossfitters get out of it is actually how to do the list,
but also teach them,
you know,
and very important.
I think he could seriously teach somebody at a snatch and 20 minutes,
but,
uh,
and the,
the technique would be perfect,
but it's not what you see in crossfit boxes Baney means.
So speaking of the snatch,
the,
um,
technically can be a pretty subtle nuanced to movement once.
What are your favorite mobility exercises?
You mentioned mobility exercises for preparing someone for a movement,
like the snatch,
the biggest problem in the snatch usually is,
uh,
out to activate the external rotators of the shoulder and out to make the
internal rotators loose.
So I spent a lot of time on different flexibility exercise.
Sometimes I teach them acupuncture points that instantly correct.
Uh,
the issue,
I mean,
you,
you took that class in New York,
so it a time savers and,
um,
the biggest issue in the snatch is actually a good year.
Rotator cuff is and uh,
we spend an hour and a half on that obviously started to do
by podcasts,
demonstrate them,
but we go to secrets as their nails or show them our,
to identify why the bar is not going into what we call the slot.
Right.
And then,
um,
we,
we also showed them a corrective exercises they could do on their own to
strengthen those muscles so they can put the barn into the slot.
And um,
is there who we can,
we can approach this from a different angle.
Yeah.
Are there mobility exercises for the shoulder?
Let's just say it's in the context of Olympic lifting or overhead lifting that
you think should be thrown out or that,
uh,
that you would not recommend people do?
Actually,
I can't answer that.
I,
I like to teach the correct way so I'm not got it.
Not over focused on the bad way.
Yeah.
I just knew so many people who have injured shoulders.
Um,
what our exercises,
just,
I'll try this one more time.
If you don't want to answer it,
it's fine.
But are there any exercises that you would,
aside from the,
the,
the balancing sort of contra lateral stuff and the cardio machines.
So there are other free weight exercises that you,
you think you would remove for novice and intermediate trainees?
I would,
there's some that I would remove for all cases.
One,
the goblet squat,
that is such a moronic exercise.
Basically you're limited by the strength of your rhomboids anterior deltoids and
the elbow flexors.
So if you can do a goblet squat and overall of your legs,
these are you going to really,
really weak legs.
You should be in a wheelchair.
So that's moronic exercise.
Uh,
a lot of the kettlebell stuff,
like the Kettlebell swings,
if ask any chiropractor,
they'll tell you their business went up for disc injuries when they add a
crossfit box opening up next door that did a lot of kettlebell swings.
Um,
I think the kettle bells swings is very harmful to the destruction.
But the thing is the,
the way it arms you,
it's like a dental cavity.
It doesn't happen overnight.
So,
uh,
you know,
you don't brush your teeth and railing basis one day early out of the cavity,
but people don't make,
you know,
so the,
it all make the link between the tenable and swing and or back problems.
Uh,
that's an exercise I really hate.
Um,
one exercise I find overrated,
just plunk,
uh,
and I don't want to fund bodily Moronic is glue,
bridges,
um,
got like the,
uh,
the kind of Supine glute bridges.
Yeah.
That's,
there's so many exercises that recruit the glutes more effective than that.
And if it was dyed great,
all Olympic lifters and power lifters would do it because success in Olympic
lifting and high jump,
long jump is glute strength dependent.
And no one does an exercise because it's a
more chronic exercise.
Uh,
the thing that had the load,
if you're in any strong,
the load,
if,
first of all,
when does it ever happen that the load is on the,
uh,
anterior pelvis area in,
in real life?
Only if you dismount and obese sexual partner.
I mean that,
that,
that movement pattern,
but an overloading their Atkinson in life.
So,
I mean,
unless you'd like to date,
we'll be swimming.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's a nonfunctional pattern.
And again,
for cervical health,
I'm not convinced it's the greatest thing for you,
but because it's like cavities,
the damage is done over time.
People don't associate the problems.
Uh,
what are good exercises for glute activation or engaging the glutes.
You can't be dead lifts and squats and any type of split squats.
I mean,
those will transfer it to ordinary activities.
You know,
everyday life activities.
They'll improve your vertical John dealing,
improve your results,
hold jumping the ability and so on.
Um,
but the thing is is that you look at it guys who we advocate as exercise,
look at her track record.
It doesn't exist the then they were pretty sad anybody.
But what I see in this industry is,
you know,
it's a very normal human nature to figure out where you are in the food chain.
And these guys want to move up the food chain by son seeing something different.
And I always use your analogy of,
uh,
if you go to do something different,
it has to be an improvement or has to be more fun.
And I use it,
the animals you could give up wearing your underwear over your jeans.
So I find that's a good example.
But
a lot of new stuff is like wearing your underwear or over your genes.
It,
it's no improvement and it's the only thing that's fun for us with people
watching you,
you know,
because they make fun of you wearing your underwear or over your genes.
So the,
the,
like I said,
there's nothing new since 1896 in my opinion.
So,
uh,
there's better ways to do the stuff from 1896,
but the concepts were there a long time ago.
Did you think there's a question about swings with the Kettlebell swing.
Do you think that kettlebell swings or harmful or,
I guess I'm curious the,
um,
are they harmful in any tech you'd given any technique for the swing or is part
of the harm from say,
a Kettlebell crossfit box in the way that they perform the Kettlebell swing?
That's it.
There's no safe way to do the Kettlebell swing is an exercise called a lumber
jack,
where use a,
uh,
basically a loaded post.
But in,
in the lumberjack,
the bar is moved vertically,
not into a swing process.
So people say,
well,
you recommend the,
yeah,
but the lumberjack,
he's like a different load pattern for the power snatch.
You look at click off,
and I were talking about this when they ask us to buy the Kettlebell swing,
the goal in weightlifting is still,
it's the most weight in the most vertical way.
So the,
the best way to lift a lot of weight,
especially keep the weight in a straight line.
The more or resentful displacements,
there's a bar that there's more wasted effort and less weight is lifted.
So,
you know,
that has been studied in biomechanics for years.
There's no,
there's no two ways about it.
So when a don't like about the Kettlebell swing,
he said,
but the way it displaces away from the dish,
not in squatting,
uh,
or snatches or cleaner,
the bar always stays close to the center of gravity.
Got It.
So I have a couple of questions from fans of the podcast who have put things out
on Twitter and Facebook.
So you've,
you've answered quite a few of them already,
but this one is from Mia Health Urban Easter.
Uh,
what are your thoughts on achieving maximum strength on a plant based diet?
Only plant place,
plant based Diet.
Never seen it.
I mean the answer's quite
the Chaz.
You need meat to get strong.
I mean,
I eat my vegetables to the animals I eat.
I mean they did the vegetable eating for me.
So
to be serious,
I've never seen a worldclass strength athlete that was only in a plan base that
I've seen octo electro vegetarians.
Uh,
uh,
I've seen one
you could call a vegetarian,
but it's still that,
uh,
egg products and dairy products,
but it Vegan,
super strong athlete,
never seen it.
Got It.
Uh,
next is from Emily House high bar versus low bar squat sumo versus conventional
dead lift.
Pros and cons.
They all have pros and cons.
The in regarding to dead lift.
Uh,
they're both good.
I would see it.
Okay.
The question is,
what is the goal?
You want to move a lot of weight for short distance so you can win a
powerlifting competition.
Will most will record olders do it in the sumo because you've got a better
mechanics.
But for training purposes,
I think you should change both.
For power lifting.
The goal is can I displace the ice amount of weight for a given range of motion?
So the low bar squat will allow you to do that.
Think about longterm health.
Uh,
you look at high bar squats.
The reason I say that is that you look the incidence of hip replacement and
power lifters versus a weightlifters,
it's much greater than power of the three years because of the,
uh,
you,
my good friend Ed Kona,
total hip replacement.
So the fact that you restrict the range of motion does in a lot of pure forms,
for example,
and the,
all the rotators of the hip to gain optimal range.
So if you are or can be,
again,
it goes back to the goal.
Do you want to compete in a powerlifting and you want to be world champion?
Well,
you got a much higher squad,
the low bar squat.
But if you looking at uh,
squatting with a lot of,
carry over to our different activities,
I would say the high bar squat,
if you're going to pick one is your best investment.
If you,
if you had to pick the high bar back squat front squat or overhead squat as the
only squat you could use for
athletes you work with,
which one would you use?
The front squat.
And this,
I have a lot of statistical data on that because
it is impossible to cheat on the front squat,
but I'm talking ass to the grass front squat,
meaning you leave a stain in the carpet in the bottom position.
Uh,
in my opinion,
for athletic purposes,
all squares should,
he'd done that wick.
The overhead squat is a screening exercise,
so it's very good to assess just with an empty bar or even a broomstick.
The potential for lower extremity injuries.
But as far as the training exercise,
you're going to be limited by your shoulder girdle strength.
So I think that you could do it as a,
you know,
what I call a change of pace workout,
but I wouldn't use it as a training exercise,
that's for sure.
And with the,
with the front squat from a technical standpoint,
do you have any particular,
assuming people aren't competing in Olympic lifting,
and do you have any preference in terms of arm placement?
Do you have the arms kind of folded back with the elbows elevated?
Do you have them crossed over?
Um,
no,
they should use it the way the Olympic lifters do it.
So a slightly wider than shoulder width,
elbows up as high as you can and actually the elbows in that locks to bar,
uh,
into right in front of your throat if you can.
If you find the exercise comfortable and the front squat,
you're not doing it correctly.
Uh,
you should feel some restriction in the neck when you front squat properly.
Of course,
after a few weeks you won't feel the,
it's like if you wear a wet t shirt,
it's uncomfortable for the first five minutes then after that to get used to it.
So people will tolerate the stress of not breathing properly within a few
workouts.
But,
um,
for example,
in sports and a lot of sports,
I have developed formulas where if I know your front squat,
let's say you incline press and your power snatch,
I can tell how fast you can speed skate or office.
You can push a bobsled or whatever else.
I call them predictive formulas.
But when I use a squat for prediction purposes,
uh,
I only use the front squat.
Got It.
This next question is from John Fox,
uh,
who is apparently a very big fan of your blog.
Literally check it every day for new articles.
And that's a,
that's strength Sensei,
strength Sensei to calm.
He's question.
He has a,
he had quite a few questions,
but I'm selecting a few here.
A one is what are the most bang for your buck?
Things that people can do to improve testosterone and sex drive.
Some people won't be happy with the answers.
Change central partners
as a route for testosterone.
Actually the best thing to increase the star stone is to low record as all
because the same,
uh,
raw material that makes testosterone and cortisol is called pregnenolone.
And then under conditions of stress,
your body is wired to preferentially go towards the cortisol pathway.
So anything that lowers cortisol,
uh,
will increase testosterone.
So for example,
diminishing the amount of radiation exposure at cell phones,
computer use a lot,
get off the fucking Facebook.
That would be one.
The so,
uh,
that,
um,
high zinc,
high protein containing foods,
I eat meat.
Uh,
this is a lot of research that backs up meat consumption for improving
testosterone.
So,
uh,
eating more meat but more red meat.
But of course,
you know,
the quality of the meat makes it a big difference.
Cold exposure to cold baths will increase testosterone.
What type of duration or frequency your or a protocol would you suggest
and not up to date on the literature?
I mean,
you know more about this topic than I do,
but that's one thing that,
uh,
I've seen some papers on but I didn't really expand on it.
But the,
I think reducing stress and quality of sleep,
quality of sleep is underrated for,
uh,
producing testosterone.
Uh,
so you need to do what you need to do.
So one of the things I recommend to you,
let's just sleep in a bat cave.
So the room you sleep in should be as dark as possible.
It's one of the things I talk a lot about seminars I can,
not powerful executive seminar.
One of the topics is the importance of sleep on regeneration,
but I think it's the most underrated one.
Uh,
it's not a question I can answer in five minutes,
but sleep neat,
uh,
called bat and decreasing stress or the four for most bang for your buck
and,
and feeling all that.
A new sexual partner,
it sounds like.
That's right.
Because the,
the,
the thing is,
is that,
you know,
this is a reality.
What is animal or a human evidence.
The
changing sexual partners increases testosterone.
But you may not,
you know,
it's not for everybody,
but the point is,
is that yes,
that question,
I'll answer it truthfully.
So this question,
I get asked a lot of caveats to this question,
but this is John's question and I think it's a very common one.
Um,
what supplements should everyone take?
A weather,
men,
women or all people in a,
in a broad age range?
I think the most underrated supplement,
if you have a perfect diet,
which is rare is magnesium.
Even when it perfect that we can get enough and we need,
I don't care what you say,
measured people's red blood cell magnesium for years.
If there's one thing that consistently see low is that one.
And when you consistently improve it,
you see changes all across blood work.
Right?
So how much magnesium,
I think males should take four grams a day.
Females 2.4.
Uh,
the second one type of magnesium,
sorry to interrupt.
Any museum.
I think the best magnesium out there is magnesium threonate if I were to pick
one,
but I preferred the different key leads.
So I use glycinate,
they use orotate.
If you look at the physiology behind it and there's lot of good research,
that's easy.
Fine is that every form of magnesium tends to go to a specific tissue.
So for example,
magnesium glycinate as a profound preference for liver and muscle tissue.
Magnesium orotate tends to work more in the vascular system.
Magnesium through an eight is more of a Gab when inducer,
therefore it improves sleep.
So personally I take two grams and they need him through and eight of the last
meal before going to bed.
And I use various forms of key lates,
uh,
like magnesium,
[inaudible] phosphate from Gaba Mag.
I used that,
that I use a man using lysinate glycinates.
Uh,
I use,
and it's good to vary to forums because as the research shows it tends to go to
different tissues.
Got It.
The second most important supplement in my opinion for the average person would
be a good,
uh,
official and it should very official.
But when they are fish oil,
I prefer to brands like the,
Oh my God,
veil from designs for l,
which as you say the name one more time please.
Omega a veil.
So veil from a designs frill.
So where do you yeah.
Added d three k one and K two.
When you add the three k one k two,
the cardiovascular benefits of the official go exponential.
Uh,
number three,
it depends on where you live around the world,
but you certainly live in the UK,
Ireland or Australia.
You are zinc deficient.
So again,
I prefer to use multiple forms of zinc t lates,
like lysinate,
Orotate,
blah,
Blah and uh,
so broadbased zinc and take that in testosterone levels.
Zinc is under estimated.
Uh,
you will find,
for example,
when I worked a lot with hockey players,
uh,
guys were trying to add,
let's say by the time they came to see me,
they usually were in their thirties.
They have usually two kids,
but they're always trying for third or fourth child and they became fertile
after about four months of,
uh,
sorry,
zinc use.
So fertility is id associated with the zinc status.
But if you look at the research,
the sync status is one of the best predictors of quote unquote maleness.
So the more androgenic you want to be,
the more synchrony,
but to detoxify foreign estrogens,
the enzymes to do that.
Also in based,
so it works in multiple patents.
Zinc is known as a great organizer and human tissues.
So you,
you can't organize chemistry properly if you don't have enough sink.
Uh,
what,
what type of
dosages do you typically recommend?
First Time clients,
you'll be surprised that you use about 180 milligrams a day for about six
months.
And if you ask Mark Houston or Esther bloom,
anybody you this clinical nutrition on a regular basis,
they will agree with that value because a 30 mil.
And the thing is,
is that in the early,
late 70,
[inaudible] you could change a guy's to Starstone fairly rapidly.
We'd only 30 milligrams of supplements a day,
but I don't see that anymore.
That doses,
you need that about six times greater in the last 30 years.
Is that just due to ground soil depletion or what is the cause?
Multiple factors?
I think there's a ground depletion,
uh,
the type of fertilizers we use,
but also the stress of the toxic load from the environment.
So if you're,
let's say putting a shampoo that has a lot of estrogenic properties,
you'll need to justify those molecules and those molecules in the pathic dots
detoxification process always almost always use sync as one of the core factors
to detoxify those estrogens.
That makes perfect sense.
Alright.
Uh,
let's shift gears just a little bit.
Have a couple more questions and then,
and um,
love to hear,
of course,
where everyone can find more information on everything you're up to.
What before we get to that,
when you think of the word successful,
who is the first person who comes to mind?
Actually,
Winston Churchill.
Why is that
this guy add balls.
I mean,
you stood up to Hitler,
you rally
the United Kingdom,
you refuse to surrender.
You said Nobel price winner in literature or few people know that,
um,
was named Britain most,
uh,
valuable Britain 2002 in east,
contributed to the feet of the Nazi empire.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
his attitude and his,
um,
he applied a lot of the success principles to like napping and so on.
And He,
uh,
he predicted a lot of things that the Americans did not listen to.
For example,
that you predicted the iron curtain.
He told the Roosevelt that you was getting screwed at the alto by Stalin
Roosevelt.
See the way too many things to the Russians.
And we've had many problems since then,
but he was a visionary.
Uh,
and he was,
he took a lot of decisions that were unpopular at the time because they required
balls and you was later found three streets to have been right in the first
place.
So,
uh,
I think that if you want to study success,
you should study,
uh,
Churchill.
Yeah.
Churchill is a fascinating,
fascinating character and also a great example of,
um,
how,
how incredible,
how incredibly productive you can be with some,
um,
very widely perceived weaknesses as well.
I mean,
just a,
definitely a whole character and,
uh,
I think a good exemplar of how to focus on your strengths.
Exactly.
Uh,
what is your favorite documentary or movie?
You know,
what,
as far as your movies,
I think that have laser like focus all day.
So for me,
a good movie involves 60 people getting killed and Bruce and way in the first 30
minutes.
And like I said,
some of the John Wick,
I mean I watch movies to distract me.
So if you ask me movies,
I like it like last time where I like gladiator,
I like movies,
he arrests a struggle,
uh,
and overcome difficulty.
But you know,
is a movie called the imitation game,
which has none of these descriptions and I really liked it.
I'm a big movie buff,
but for me movies is to take my mind away from what I do every day.
Uh,
you know,
obviously I run high in dopamine and that's still calling.
So
action movies are a far better choice for me then sleepless in Seattle.
But
you know,
the thing I really like,
national geographic,
the documentaries.
Do you have,
I really like learning about animal life.
My daughter and I share that stuff.
Um,
I read like to learn about ecosystems,
so those shy,
you know,
I like the history channel and not a big movie TV watcher.
If I'm going to watch something,
it's usually a movie.
Did a dye rent.
Uh,
when I'm overseas and I'm sick and tired of teaching Ela,
go watch a movie to take my mind off.
I find it's a good,
I like Quentin Tarantino movies.
I mean,
I like,
I like usually action based stuff.
There's,
um,
I've,
I've a movie recommendation that you might enjoy.
There's a movie called,
and I'm going to butcher this,
but,
uh,
when profit,
so a profit about this young Middle Eastern kid who gets thrown into a French
prison and gets adopted by the core skin mafia and it tracks his growth from the
lowest on the totem pole to the highest and the totem pole are,
it's an amazing action movie.
Yeah.
And really,
really good.
You see at 22 bullets?
No,
I haven't seen 22 bullets.
That's a native French movie with Charles.
I know,
which is a great movie about a guy that tries to retire from the math yet and
they don't let them.
It's like,
actually,
that's a great one.
22 bullets.
I'll check it out.
Uh,
in the last say six to 12 months,
what $100 or less purchase has most positively impacted your life?
Actually it was a gift,
so I'm not sure what the price was when it can't be that hot.
It's called the bamboo bench.
I featured it on my website.
All it is,
it's a sliced foam roller incented,
a leather condom with Velcro straps and you put it over a regular bench and it
has this half moon shape where your spine rests.
So when you do pressing movements,
you can drop the elbows much further,
uh,
than the wood irregular bench.
So it allows for more free Kepler,
uh,
movement and it's uh,
allows for a greater range of motion when you lift,
but it allows you for pain free,
uh,
providing present ha and it's called the bamboo bench.
Yeah.
All it is,
it's like a condom that you put on a bench that as a half moon,
um,
as a spine roller inside of it.
And it,
if you go to my website and you search under Babin bench is a video that I shot
and strict guard explaining how to use it.
But for,
you know,
for what it costs over which you have to invest,
it's a great,
uh,
investment on the health and of your shoulders.
Very cool.
That sounds like my next purchase.
The w what does,
uh,
what does the first 60 to 90 minutes of your day look like?
People are fascinated by morning rituals.
So just in your ideal sort of,
let's just say it's a work day.
What is your,
what is your ideal 60 to 90 minutes look like?
It depends if I'm on the road or not,
but let's say are not on the road.
Okay.
Like today.
So I wake up early,
I tend to wake up at four.
Why do I wake up at four?
Well,
nobody's going to bother me.
So I get two hours to myself.
So if that week had my daughter,
I can do whatever I want to do for two hours before I wake her up,
make her breakfast and drive to school.
So,
and we come up with a ravishing appetite.
So everyday I start when I'm at home with some type of wild meat,
some type of nuts and sometimes berries or Avocados.
So,
uh,
I eat that.
Then I make coffee and I'm quite a fanatical about the way me coffee.
Uh,
how to make your coffee.
Well,
for example,
the wall,
they're asked to be near freezing point.
The reason why I do that is that it takes longer to warm up the water because it
takes longer to warm up.
Then there's more time for the steam to diffuse through the coffee beans.
Therefore the coffee has more caffeine,
more uh,
of all the antioxidants.
When you drink that coffee,
if I make you a cup of coffee,
Tim,
today,
you may fall asleep Valentine's Day.
So people who've been in my house and drink great coffee,
these start to having convulsions and their faces after two sips.
But I really like very cold coffee out.
And one thing that is high in pesticides is actually a coffee.
It's one more spray plants on the planet.
So I get my beans either from the Dominican Republic.
I've got a client who owns their own plantation.
And when I go to the drs stock up or,
uh,
one of my assistant teachers,
Carlos Castro is from the Columbia and he brings me in,
uh,
organic coffee from Colombia or I buy the one from Kona Island in Hawaii.
So I really like the coffee beans,
uh,
to be,
of choice.
So I drink coffee and then typically just black or how do you take your coffee?
Like my soul.
Okay.
Sometimes I put a,
actually coconut oil in it if I need to get a bit more wired.
Uh,
sometimes they use very,
very heavy cream,
like about three,
5%.
Uh,
it's funny because I was in London at the Marriott and there's a polish waiter
and this for coffee and the guy comes in,
we'd already,
what the British called devil cream in it.
And they go,
Oh,
you know,
I like my coffee like that.
It just says I read your post every day.
But
sometimes they scream,
but probably 70% of the time I drink it black,
like my soul.
But the,
um,
and then I read,
I like to read one hour on a non specific to my job stuff.
So I may read,
let's say a biography on Churchill or a May read a book like a 59 seconds.
They're more what you would call self improvement books.
I read recently a book,
I probably read a book a day.
So I read,
I'm a very good speed reader.
So I read a book on resilience or this morning at breakfast as reading a fringe
book on German grammar because
it sounds like a page Turner.
And I was in,
in Germany last month and I realized I had lost a lot of my German.
So I said,
okay,
I've got to catch up my German.
Or sometimes what I do is I'll type in sentences on being translate and I look
at the German equivalent or the Swedish agreement,
whatever language you want to learn,
just the sentences I use all the time in my practice.
So like keep your back straight Galore and a squad,
blah,
blah.
You know?
So I do that.
And then,
yeah,
did not page turners,
but it's stuff I like to read.
Or even when I'm overseas,
I buy classic comic books,
like Asterix in let's say in Swedish or looky,
looky in Swedish or whatever.
And I read those because it's a fun way to learn a foreign language.
We felt we stressing myself.
That's exactly the same thing that I do also by bay because it's also,
I'm heavy on dialogue.
So yes,
so you get conversation.
I know,
not to say you're under arrest and 76 languages,
but the thing is is that,
uh,
and then after that it'd be ever one hour specific to my job.
So,
and I like to read a lot of my colleagues stuff.
So one guy I really like is Josh Brian.
So you just wrote a really good book on interval training.
So that's what I'm going to read tomorrow.
Um,
and then I don't read much on the Internet because I find there's too much
bullshit.
So,
uh,
a,
um,
I use a kindle a lot because it allows me to flip the pages faster.
And what I like about the kindle is it can actually,
I liked what I find interesting.
And then at the end of my reading I reread what I had highlighted,
which increases the retention by under 70%.
So,
uh,
and then on Sundays I tend to reread the highlights of all the books I read.
So that goes up to 95%.
People always wonder how come I got a good memory and there's some tricks to it.
So repetition is important.
And then,
um,
after that,
then I started my day at work.
So I'll write,
I'll true whenever I
need to on the road.
Oh.
I usually,
if I drove my daughter as soon as they get back,
I trained,
I've got a very good gym in my house.
Um,
if I'm on the road,
I wake up,
eat breakfast,
I do some reading.
It depends on the distance of the gym.
What is your go to breakfast at home?
It's always a wild meat always.
How do you prepare that?
Typically,
I typically a frightened Goldwater got it at,
so it could be,
so this morning was chicken breasts,
but I rarely eat a chicken for breakfast,
always a red meat.
But I joined some different today and then I always have and that,
uh,
what it's wellness,
I read like naked aimia notes with our very that,
so I don't give up intolerances.
Nn in Colorado you can get very good berries year round.
So eat sometimes berries or eat avocados.
Um,
and then like I said,
the coffee on the road,
it's one of the reasons why I stayed at Marriott worldwide.
Is this the only place I'll serve steak and eggs.
So it,
you know,
it's really hot when he asked for staking.
Like in Italy,
he might as well ask the question when the aquarium on top of your head,
they're like,
well,
stage,
you know,
you eat for breakfast.
So,
uh,
in Sweden,
the,
these,
uh,
ethnic shrimp that I like it,
they're very small shrimp,
so I'll buy it out of the supermarket,
keep it in my minibar.
So in morning I may have shrimp and cashews for breakfast.
So one thing that I don't negotiate on ever is breakfast.
I'm a maniac about breakfast.
I don't want to quash our back in prison.
Eggs as my friends would call him for breakfast.
And the salmon is always farmed salmon.
It tastes disgusting.
So,
uh,
in Manchester there was no way I could get steak and eggs for breakfast.
So my sister and I,
we bought sardines,
so,
and sardines and Brazil nuts for breakfast the next day.
So I don't negotiate on that.
For me,
I eat meat,
fish or seafood and some nuts that I find.
For me it's been one of the secrets to my success because when you teach,
you got to pay attention.
You got to remember what you got to say,
you gotta be enthusiastic.
And if I were to eat with hotels,
typically give a,
and we'll do so well.
Even when I fly,
if I go to Europe,
I only fly a Swiss air or a f bounce because if Atlanta Alexander connection and
Air France has the best Biss Mr First Class Lounge in the world,
second is a Swiss air.
And when I fly west,
if I go to Australia,
I always fly with 'em
air New Zealand because again,
the quality of the lounge is important to me.
Yeah.
For the food,
for the food and you know,
can you take a shower,
you know,
American based,
uh,
airlines are useless.
United Delta American fuck,
you may fly with Air Buzz Atlanta,
you probably get better
service.
And you know,
I find with these airlines I named it the actually believe in quality service,
you know,
and uh,
for several efficate Air France is great.
Like cattle ended from Dusseldorf in Paris.
Somebody was there to pick me up,
but my name drove me to the first class lounge.
I didn't have to clear customs.
They take your passport for you,
they go do it for you.
The loose dancer does the same thing.
So the Swiss air,
and I don't know if people say,
well you waste money traveling first class.
I don't believe that because I give them much better seminar,
fly first class.
And if a fly economy I can,
you know,
one of my unique abilities is it,
I can fall asleep.
And the shooting yard.
I can sleep anywhere,
anytime,
but I need to sleep when I fly over.
And when you fly first class,
you're guaranteed quality sleep because there's no one year old kid crying,
you know,
uh,
some guy opening up this Tupperware with I can microwave and Broccoli so he can
say I'm a snob.
Yes I am.
But I haven't over the years,
even as early as 1982,
one when I was paying for my own flights,
I've always flown business or first because the quality of your teaching will
dictate your success of the quality of your coaching.
Will they take their success and that will pay,
weighed enough your first class tickets.
I've had discussions with people about that,
but I still believe,
and also it's a mindset.
You know,
you want a first class life fly first class.
Yeah.
I've um,
I've found for myself,
you know,
it took me a long time.
My family didn't grow up with a lot of money.
It took me a long time to,
to make the transition from economy to business.
And the only reason that I made that jump was because I tried to save money on
an international flight specifically and had to do a speaking engagement than s
next day.
And it was a disaster because I couldn't sleep.
And it was,
uh,
it,
it all came down to preserving the ability to sleep if there's some type of,
of business engagement on the other end.
Um,
if you could have one bill
board anywhere,
uh,
what would it say and where would it be
addressing question probably you would say know yourself,
where would you put it in Times Square?
It was great.
I spoke probably about Malaysian density because the,
I look at my industry but I think shooting lessons,
right?
I love to shoot.
I think it's a great relaxation exercise acid and,
and my shooting instructor follows a lot of strength industry
and he said they had the same issues in the shooting industry with people
wanting the attention of the consumer.
Right.
And I think that,
uh,
the,
the key to,
to success in anything is know yourself first and then,
you know,
call,
cough.
He was telling students that there's one thing that he keeps constant is,
is with a thin prep.
He's learned over the years not to mess with that,
but he says the other,
uh,
45 weeks or so,
left out of the year,
Egos on a day to day basis.
And he says,
he says,
brining is like food.
Sometimes you eat more,
sometimes you eat less,
you have to eat when you're hungry.
So,
you know,
if you look at it,
it's a very simplistic way to explain training,
but it's very true.
So,
you know,
he explains why you only squats twice a week.
A lot of guys in this field,
it was quite nine times a week.
But if you look at it as longevity,
it's really high remain fairly much injury free.
Um,
and the thing is is that,
you know,
for example,
Ed Kong,
he as a way to train is very different than would poke off with dude.
But I respect that a lot.
But I found over the years all these successful people
figured out what worked best for them.
And,
uh,
it's correct gas guys like me,
you know,
the so called Gurus or the census for advice.
But at the end of the day you have to make the decision.
I mean I can make you make a more enlightened decision because I made a lot of
mistakes.
I mean the only guy I know who's never,
never,
never made a mistake in his life pumps gas in a gas station in British Columbia
in Columbia,
you know,
he's my age and made a mistake.
You still makes eight bucks an hour.
So you learn by making mistakes and you know,
the,
there's a saying good judgment comes from experience.
But experience comes from bad judgment.
So I tell on my seminars,
I often tell stories of our screwed up metal at the Olympics but didn't make the
same mistake twice.
And you know,
that's why like in speed skating it's probably the spoiler I'm most successful
in because in the early on,
I mean quite a few mistakes and I learned not to do them again.
What advice would you give to your 30 year old self
start working so much?
I used to work 20 hours a day,
Tim,
it's a lot of hours plus a week training.
So I thought that sleep was for wimps.
Well it's not true.
I mean
I think there's another book that I read in 91 which changed my outlook.
It was called life 101 and uh,
it depends.
It's an old books.
Sometimes you'll funders to authors.
Sometimes there's one author,
but he was actually only one real author to the book.
So eventually it was Peter McDonald.
But he taught me to distinguish the difference between a fantasy and a goal.
And I won't give you the,
the,
the punchline,
but it has to do a lot with,
uh,
you have to do the exercise in the book.
So in the book you'll say,
you'll give some theory.
You was always in a funny way.
Then he'll say,
you have 20 minutes,
yes or no.
If it's yes,
I'll do the exercise.
You don't have to,
don't keep on reading.
And the people will keep on reading,
never get the full essence of the book.
If he,
if he asks you,
you have 20 minutes,
yes or no,
you don't have 20 minutes,
but the book down next time you have 20 minutes to do the exercise.
But that was a life changing book for me.
And after that,
my uh,
success at the international international levels skyrocketed.
One,
I applied those principles.
But if I were to to think back on my life,
I should have had more fun and I should have work a lot less.
And then actually when I read your book,
I was already starting to evolve,
which more free time and better organization and you recommend to me in personal
conversation more books like the one by your friend Edward,
their Ooda or that it's about simplify your life.
I forget the,
the author.
Anyway,
I read him,
I decided to dive less goals and the more you evolve,
if against simplify,
simplify,
simplify.
And um,
uh,
I tell that to some of my best students,
like say,
Hey,
go on vacation.
Uh,
it's not so hard with my non British,
non American students,
but Canadians,
Americans and British tend to weigh over work,
you know?
Yeah,
I agree.
It's,
I'm blacking it out ahead of time.
Really,
really,
really critical.
Putting those things on the calendar,
the calendar so that work doesn't swell to fill all of the voids.
Will Charles,
this is,
this is been a lot of fun.
I always love chatting and catching up.
Where can people find everything about you and what would you like them to check
out?
The best place to find my stuff.
Is that a strength?
sensei.com.
Uh,
and then if people want to attend seminars is an omelet call a calendar of
events as probably the most simplistic way to,
it's a world map and there's like arrows.
So if you don't want to Charles so much and let's say you live in Australia and
you see them coming to Perth and click the proof flagging and he'll tell you his
seminars.
They are,
but also these different ways to search.
If you based on topic,
what type of class you want.
And uh,
my next project is I'm working on a membership only site.
The reason is is because of social media.
People ask these questions.
I don't have any time on social media to explain them,
but an a membership site,
people will be able to say,
I'll say for example,
uh,
this month and we're,
we to really go into detail on choosing the right set,
choosing the right rep range.
Right.
And I'll talk to Richard,
that's the 90 minutes.
So people will be able to watch that and I'll give routines and recipes and tips
and anticipate it to be a very successful site,
uh,
because there's a demand for it and people are willing to pay a nominal fee,
which is less than 20 bucks a month to get top level information because you
know,
Facebook is nice.
I leave tips there and I leave links to my website,
but it never allows for,
and I got this advice from you actually for videos on me explaining something.
The written word never really catches everything.
Uh,
and there's a lot to be learned from body language.
And if I explain it technique,
I can explain it in writing,
but you could tell by the questions that people didn't understand it at all.
So most people are visual learners.
So the membership sites,
which should be out within the next three months will be up soon.
And of course it will broadcast that and you'll announce that on strength.
Sensata come on.
Where can people find you on social media if they want to just receive those
updates as you publish them?
Uh,
strength Sensei on Facebook.
Got It.
Go ahead.
I'm sorry.
And I've got a strength sensei equivalent in German,
Spanish,
Russian,
and French.
So if you go strength Sensei,
Deutsch,
you,
they'll be the German version and French sensei that are false sense.
It lot of thoughts on this Spanish show.
So depending on your native tongue,
ah,
the same information is there and I've got about a dozen translation in
different languages to my sites.
So English is not your first language and you're more comfortable,
let's say with German or Dutch or French.
Uh,
the most popular articles get translated,
um,
and even in Russia.
So it's picking up,
I mean,
my website,
this,
and then I think it's 83,000 on Alexis for being in,
in that new business for a year and a half.
It's pretty good score.
Yeah,
and I will obviously everybody listening link to all of the sites and uh,
to Charleston social media in the show notes
so you guys can find the links and resources
and so on@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash podcast all spelled out.
Uh,
any parting parting comments or parting words?
Charles?
Well,
thank you.
I mean you,
it's a great honor for me to be in the same list of
invitees as Schwarzenegger in Anthony Robbins.
Those are big names.
So,
uh,
you're a big name to yeah,
but you know what,
it's like,
it's a big pleasure for me and I really appreciate your time and the ability to
be reaching your audience.
I think that's what I want the most grateful for.
He said,
I think that people who have it eel perceived notion in me,
uh,
we'll know more of a human side.
And um,
I think that's a big factor in life and I'm forever grateful for the
opportunity,
Tim.
Oh,
my pleasure.
I really wanted people to have the chance to kind of sit down with us at the
table and and really dig deep and get to know you a bit,
so I really appreciate it.
I'm sure people will let us know if they want around too,
which I'm sure will be the case and until next time,
everybody,
thank you for listening.
Thank you.
This episode is brought to you by Athletic Greens.
I get asked all the time,
if you could only use one supplement,
what would it be?
My answer is inevitably athletic Greens.
It is your all in one nutritional insurance.
I recommended it in the four hour body,
did not get paid for that and I travel with it to avoid getting sick.
I take it in the mornings to ensure optimal performance.
It just covers all my basis.
If I can't get what I need through whole food meals throughout the rest of the
day,
and you can get 50 oh my gosh,
50% off.
Yes,
If you go to athleticgreens.com forward slash Tim that's athleticgreens.com
forward slash Tim,
check it out.
It's tasty but more important.
It will help you not screw up when you're doing your nutritional plannings.
For me,
it just covers the basis,
takes a load off my mind,
puts a lot in my body and check it out.
athleticgreens.com forward slash.
Tim
this episode is brought to you by 99 designs your one stop shop for all things
graphic design related.
I've used 99 designs for everything from banner ads to book covers,
including sketches and mock ups that led to the four hour body,
which later became number one New York Times Number One Wall Street Journal and
the brainstorming.
A lot of it took place with designers from around the world and here's how it
works.
Whether you need a t shirt,
a business card,
a website,
an APP thumbnail,
whatever it might be,
you submit that project and designers from around the world.
We'll send you sketches and mock ups and designs.
You choose your favorite and you have an original that you love or you get your
money back.
It's that straight forward,
and many of who are listening have already used it and created some amazing
things that I'll be sharing it in the future.
But in the meantime,
if you want to see some of my competitions,
some of the book covers,
as well as get a free $99 upgrade,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
that's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim and until next time,
thank you for listening.